Four three,
two,
one
eh,
and
we're live.
This is a bummer of a fight week,
but also an awesome fight week.
I'm very excited.
Did you see the,
the latest count down?
What does it,
uh,
all access,
what do they call it?
No embedded.
Embedded.
Yeah.
Try to call it with the name of those.
They're all the same but all access
embedded 24 seven.
That is very good.
I should,
I should remember the name.
It's very good.
They're all,
yeah,
they're on this,
this new one is really good cause it's
got Max Holloway running on a treadmill,
two treadmills over from norma madoff
who's also running on a treadmill and
they're fucking very cool to each other.
It's very interesting.
It could be thanked him for taking the
time when she should.
She should.
Thanks for taking the fight.
And then they have the same weight
coach.
Like Kinda,
yeah,
that's crazy.
Lockhart,
right?
[inaudible]
card is d.
This is lockhart working with both of
them.
So Lockhart was like,
Lockhart is legit.
Like he goes over calculations of like
how much you weigh,
how much water you're going to take.
And he's weighing things out.
It took them an hour and a half to do
the calculations.
Yeah.
It wasn't like,
hey,
we're going to wing this.
It's like,
no,
no.
We're going to do this weight cut
correctly.
And he's got it down to the day,
you know,
like it's six days to lose.
He think he was one 71 is that,
is that the,
I was wondering what,
what did he start at?
Does it one 71 so I think he's got to
lose 16 pounds.
What's crazy is when Max was on my show,
I was talking to him a little bit off it
and this is on record,
on let's build anything that he didn't
say,
but he just goes,
you know,
I've,
with the injury,
Jesus credit embedded I think is better
than that.
UFC,
not UFC,
the HBO ones.
I think it's been 24 seven how dare you,
I think it's better than only four seven
when there's a big fight.
Yeah.
You know,
watching the generals or blah,
I think,
well,
I think in general they're better
because they do more of it.
But a 24 seven they're good.
They're fucking good.
Very good.
Liev Schreiber.
Oh,
I'd love that Bro.
Watch her words on that guy.
But I like these better.
Remember I only cat leach driver.
Yeah.
Was like till night hair wingo but it
was nowhere near as.
Yeah,
it was horrible.
I find this because there's almost no
narration,
right?
Yeah.
It's almost just,
it tells a story.
Footage.
I want to see the footage.
I would have liked the video of when
they called Max with the fight,
cause from what I heard,
he goes,
it could be that stuff's getting the
world.
Fuck yeah,
let's go.
What?
Just insane.
I was like,
oh,
why don't they have a video of that?
But no one knew.
I don't think they knew,
you know,
to to turn the video on.
I don't think Max knew whether they were
calling him amazing video of him,
especially if he wins.
This is my thing with Max is I think
could be,
was the toughest fight in the world on
six days notice.
I'd rather fight anybody else in the
world and could be one six days because
this style in just his tenacity,
but with Max win,
lose or draw,
whatever happens Saturday night if you
don't respect.
And like him even more after this,
you're a moron,
you're a champions on abroad and like
Max Holloway's on that would be willing
to take this fight on six days notice.
And also I should say coming off of a
broken foot.
Correct.
So he had a pull out of a fight with a
broken foot with Frankie Edgar.
What's just happened?
So I mean,
how healed izzy and then like it said on
my show,
he was saying,
you know,
I've been doing some Jujitsu,
been the swing of things for me,
it's good because I haven't been balls
deep into training.
I've been just been a little just to
know getting a light workout,
but it gives me time with my family.
And he goes,
which NGOs,
you know this in camp,
you're present but you're not,
which is true.
And he goes,
you know,
so I'm going through it.
I'm,
I'm with my son in the family,
but I'm thinking about something else.
He goes,
so this has been good for me to really
focus on my family.
That was what,
two weeks ago?
Three weeks ago.
Wow.
So then pay him you're fighting could be
even the reason why he wants to fight
Khabib is cause he thinks could be the
best pound for pound fighter in the
world.
Yeah.
And which is nuts because you know when
you look at it could be dresnick.
It's good.
It's,
it's,
it doesn't blow your hair back.
He's 25 and Oh for God's sake it's good.
But it's not like all this crazy,
you know,
big names on his regular.
But you talked,
I was just in San Jose.
John Fitch goes,
dude,
and this is John Fitch.
Yeah.
You know it could be,
you know,
welterweight goat.
He's fucking not cope.
He's got damn good.
He goes,
I've never seen anyone my lifetime like
could be.
He goes,
I fought GSP in his prime.
He would beat him.
That's how good he is.
DC said he's the pound for pound.
Greatest fighter he's ever seen.
DC said that he had fights with them
like dcs was the heavyweights
strikeforce champion.
He said,
he goes,
dude,
we got to war.
We go to war war.
Like imagine that DC's a willa,
he's jacked.
I mean DC's got some body fat on him.
He's strong as a fucking ox.
You see soak at downtown.
So fun to watch when DC throws Josh
Barnett through the air when they fought
strikeforce,
you just go,
Jesus,
when we need to handle fight was
offensive.
That goddamn American,
it was offensive.
He ragdolled Hendo and couldn't be a
cooler guy like the nicest guy ever.
DC might be the nicest fighter of all
time.
One of my favorite people here,
Max,
they're up there.
I love them from Isis fighters.
I don't know Max as well as I would
know.
Do you see,
because I've done so many shows with
them,
but for DC as good as he is to say that
him and Khabib go to war.
I'm like,
that's crazy to Josh Thompson is the cap
ne Kay said,
you know Ed Ruth Penn state and three
time national champion freak.
Just aren't doing it.
My main belt door,
complete freak wrestling.
He,
I was in San Jose and he,
I did a show with him and I go,
what were you doing?
He goes,
I just came from practice.
Could be second class practice and go,
what was he doing?
He goes,
oh,
just straight wrestling.
I said,
uh,
who was your wrestling?
He was said,
Ruth,
I,
oh my God,
the Penn state like legend.
He goes,
yeah man,
how's that go down?
And he's like,
only one of them's gone down.
And it could be like,
what ruth?
And he goes,
oh,
he goes,
Bro,
it,
I've never seen anything like it.
So there's just this legend of five.
They skipped when they tell me,
it scares me like Jesus.
Well,
what do we get to see it in action?
When you saw the Barboza fight,
he's walking towards him like a Zombie
gets a hold of them.
And just rag dolls.
I'm just rag dolls.
But this is what's great about this
fight and that's what makes our sport so
specialists.
Yeah,
I'm super bummed.
I've been in deep depression because
Ferguson fell out,
and we've talked about this off here,
but our sports so special because what
Max Holloway has the chance to do
Saturday night,
if he can beat him,
if he can somehow pull that out.
There's nothing like in professional
sports.
There's nothing like it.
If Lebron goes out,
the team still goes on.
It's whatever.
If Tom Brady gets hurt,
it sucked,
but they still play here.
You know man,
Max has a huge chance now are the odds
stacked against him?
Good God.
Are they ever,
there couldn't be a worst matchup for
him,
but it,
what's the one Achilles heel if there is
one for Khabib,
a guy who can strike going backwards.
Max Salaries Pretty fucking good at
going backwards.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a fascinating fight.
If there was no controversy,
if it wasn't like six day time period
for hand,
great.
Yeah,
I know.
It's kind of cool.
You don't have to fight.
That's been like,
that was a nate when nate took on connor
and the first,
here's the difference though.
Nate's the bigger guy,
right?
the more seasoned guy there.
So for nate,
it's like,
yeah,
it was short notice,
but that's a rough matchup for connor.
Connor.
It should be an underdog in that fight.
They wouldn't find it at the same weight
class.
So that makes a little more sense.
But wait a minute.
They do nate.
Nate fights at 55 uh,
before that though,
he's fighting at 70,
right?
Oh No,
no,
no.
He only fought three times at seven.
But he saw that seventies the point he
fired a college never fought at 70.
Right.
But if con when Carter fought him at 70,
that was Saturday.
Yeah.
[inaudible] 70 pounder.
Right.
But I mean,
nate,
when he fought 70 it didn't go well.
I mean,
who did he fight?
He fought Rory Macdonald.
70 tough.
Who else did he fight?
We will see if I had 70 his fights at 70
I think wasn't great at,
no,
he didn't lose all of them was in grade
one.
Wasn't great at 70.
How,
but the thing is,
he's the bigger man.
He's,
he's a bigger guy.
But if they agreed to fight at one 55
and he would make the one 55 weight,
100% yes,
it's,
there was all this talk about him being
so much bigger than conor.
Oh,
he's bigger for sure.
He's taller,
he's taller,
he's a major,
he's a bigger guy.
It's around heavier when he gets
heavier,
but when they fight at 55 he makes that
weight.
And Connor makes that weight tough too.
They both struggled to make one 55 it's
a much easier cut for counter at 55 it's
not the hardest cut.
But when you look at the difference
between how he looks physically when he
fought nate at one 70 and how he looks
when he's,
you know,
one 45 he was awful.
I was going to say he's on,
Donna can make one 45 nate could nav.
I mean there's,
there's no show me could've made it.
We got his leg ultimate fighter when he
was killed.
A leg off.
You don't have to like real list.
He's not making 40 was very thin during
the ultimate fighter days.
Remember we have to be a fighter,
right?
So you have to make weight basically
three times in a row.
Well,
I just think he filled in too.
I mean,
he was really young back then.
100% but you have to maintain a lower
weight.
That's the closest fight to it though.
I agree with that fight.
The same kind of balls that nate has is
like what?
What?
But Max,
the difference is that like Max has
taken on a guy that everybody's
avoiding.
No one's been able to solve the riddle
of Khabib.
No one's even ever even put them in
jeopardy.
Like he's,
he's like the Johnson hit him.
But that really wasn't in a while.
It was going a bit,
we were talking about that the other
day.
Who knows what was going on in that
fight because that was a fight where he
had the same issue,
cutting weight that he did when he had
to pull out of the Ferguson fight.
His body shut down.
Right.
So who knows?
He had that same issue with the Michael
j.
He might've been severely compromised in
that fight,
even though he beat the fuck out of.
Agree.
The difference between Mcgregor and
Dheas is the both keep it on the feet
really,
right?
Yeah.
He has a phenomenal boxer comes
phenomenal striker,
Max Holloway.
Phenomenal striker could be phenomenal
grappler.
So it's a,
it's even more of a task because could
be,
he was not going to sit there and strike
with him.
That's your one way to win.
Cool.
I'm the best grappler on earth.
Yeah.
He'll entertain it for a little bit,
but if you,
if you want you down,
there's literally no one in the world
from,
I'll say one 55 to one 17 he's not going
to take that.
I want to see,
I really want to see him in some
straight grappling competition here in
this.
Yeah.
Hearing that about how amazing he is in
the training room.
I'll tell you what,
from a guy like dc,
I know,
and,
and Fitch,
I mean you're talking about in the hall,
like pioneers of the sport animals.
I want to see him against Woodley 70 I
think 70 is his natural weight class.
Yeah,
I think he'd probably be a lot
healthier.
Imagine that.
Imagine being stronger and healthcare.
It Woodley and Khabib.
Jesus what?
But Woodley's at different thing man,
you,
you miss you,
you fuck up and you,
you leave yourself in a position to get
hit with one of those nuclear bombs.
Oh knock you out.
Woodley could put people to sleep and he
can grab was acid rap his ass off,
hard to take down and puts people to
sleep with one shot.
I don't think he gets his due.
And I think the best evidence is the two
fights that people point to where they
say that like Woodley should have done
better.
Those are the Thompson fights.
The end of my,
the my fight.
But Maya,
it never got hurt.
Like he,
he hit my a bunch of times but it was
uneventful cause he was hurt.
Woodley was her early in the first round
with the shoulder.
He fucked his shoulder up.
But honestly,
my the,
we should fight my,
if you don't want to go to the ground
100% but my point is in those two fights
with Thompson Woodley was the one who
hurt Thompson.
He hurt him that bad in both fights.
Almost stopped him in both fights.
Yeah.
I don't see them ever of again,
but I hear you.
Great fight hard path.
It was a crazy UFC 200 card and that was
on it.
I wouldn't be mad.
I mean,
he's one of the dough as a main event.
I get it.
I like twice.
Wow.
Cool.
Yeah.
No,
that's a super complicated equation.
Upset,
upset though.
They're just not good dance and the same
thing.
If they just said no,
this time it's going to be different.
I'm going to war.
[inaudible]
fuck you.
And then two rounds and you like bastard
is circling each other.
That's like Dana on Ferguson and Khabib.
He's like,
that fights never happened to a fifth
time not happening.
I'm like,
I get it.
I get it,
man.
It's such a bummer though.
Let's talk business like I don't know
how many paper views this was going to
do,
but for the hardcore fans,
this was a big one.
This was a big one because this is the
first time Khabib is finding a guy
that's super versatile.
They can fight.
Standing up,
can knock you out with one shot.
Tough is fuck has incredible endurance
and can grab off his back and the most
dangerous guy could be will ever face.
Yeah.
Tony Ferguson has the perfect style to
test what was so we could really find
out where could bebes Zach cause we know
we're Tony's at we and we kind of know
where could bebes at do we?
We kind of do.
We said the Barboza fight in my opinion
was the best example of it.
Dos Santos.
Dot.
Los Angeles was great.
It's old school.
Dos Anjos.
That's a dose.
Angeles also compromise to make one 55
right dose Angeles,
they wants 70 different animal.
That's a different fucking animal.
That's a totally different piece and
that I think dos Anjos is one of those
guys where you point to a perfect
example of a guy whose body just was not
allowing him to compete at one 55
agrees.
He's an,
he's a fucking animal in his mind.
I mean he,
no one works harder than that guy.
You see that guy trained,
but yes,
I have you seen in person [inaudible]
monster,
however.
And how about he's fighting Colby
Covington in Brazil and Brazil.
Troy that colby,
good luck.
Call me.
Good God.
Security.
Security,
super hard to take down.
Real hard to take down and pour rootle
leg kicks and I don't know,
he said,
well I fucking,
yeah,
what?
90 minute but video he's been doing
every day,
but his legs are gigantic.
Rumpy romp that Brazilian shit or on of
his just he,
I don't know what squats,
front squats,
dude,
I don't know what kind of crazy shit
he's doing.
I know he did some training in the past
a lot with nick.
Curse on at a speed of sport.
Nick helped him quite a bit.
Nicks,
you know the Marvin Marinovich a
disciple and he does all that crazy shit
than marv had bj doing.
He was doing,
he's got a ton of videos online though.
[inaudible] working with Perello.
Jason Parillo.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Is he still Sanchez and I got to think
EAC.
I remem I remember seeing him at the
root.
Could Jason Parillo the greatest coach
of all?
Like he's like,
you're having problems with the career.
Come here and just being cyborg.
I mean just these monsters and you know
what?
Good Dude,
great gun and doesn't want the
spotlight.
Zero.
You didn't want to be out on camera.
Doesn't want anything done.
When I was telling him,
I think he's doing a great job,
dude.
Shakes your hand.
Looks you in the eye.
Like he's right there.
He's right there.
Thank you.
He's like write to any,
won't work with just tenure either,
which is what I like.
I like what he did with bisping help
bisbing a lot.
We became world champion.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's a fucking great coat.
Back to Khabib.
You know who I think,
and I'm not just saying this because
he's my boy of known for it,
but you knew who I think could be his
Achilles heel.
Who matches up better with them than
anyone who everyone's overlooking.
Brian Ortega.
Ooh,
that's a good point.
Brian would take is a big dude at 55
easy weight cut for him and put him on
the ground on the ground.
He's the most dangerous guy in the world
right now.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think the way he locks up submissions,
it's very different.
It's like if everybody else is hitting
it at a seven or an eight or take his
hit into that 10 where you watching,
you go,
oh,
that's different and you haven't seen
it.
So it could be who he's,
how he's grappled fricking grizzly bears
since he was four.
He and he seen Sabo,
he seen black belt in Jujitsu.
He's seen all this stuff.
You're not going to catch them with oric
take.
It's a little different and he actually
encourages you to go to the ground and
he's,
he's dangerous on his feet,
but on the grounds where he thrives.
Isn't it funny how that thing about
going to the ground?
What does a bride says?
Our tag or wrote for the record,
Dana called me yesterday to see if I had
stepping against Khabib since Max hadn't
responded yet.
I said yes.
Eventually Max replied and gay.
Dana gave him the fight.
If all goes according to plan,
I'll get my turn at both of them.
Ooh,
it's phenomenal.
Fight.
Fine.
Just stylistically I went,
Ooh,
and if I'm could be,
could be goes,
why would I fight?
Our tell was phenomenal fighter,
but he didn't have a belt in a big name
and it's the most dangerous site for
him,
I think,
and it's,
it's also mean or tag.
It became a much bigger star with the
Frankie Edgar knockout.
Much bigger star,
but it's a ways to go.
Yeah.
Max Holloway is one of the best fighters
on the planet.
That's a really interesting fight.
Tor or take has got,
there's something about his Jujitsu.
It's like,
it's on.
It just ramped up and sharpened down to
like such a,
just a razor's edge man.
When he grabs a hold of stuff you like,
you have very little room to get out,
you know,
and he sets it up from the clinch and
it's a very unconventional and the head
snap switch like Tony Ferguson and the
dark jokes where he does he know snap
city.
However,
why I wanted to see in this ferguson
could be fight with the snap city is
like Josh Thomson Fitch or like,
oh no,
we've never seen could be because his
neck snapped down ever that it's for
him.
It's a pride thing.
Grown up where he grew up there.
No one snaps his neck down.
He'd known snapping them down.
It doesn't work.
Well that's Tony Steam.
They go watch,
watch.
No one's ever snap at his neck down.
Avar wow.
Yeah.
That's so crazy.
It's like nursing him lose around.
Like why,
what are we doing?
These goddamn legends,
people like this and I'm drinking the
Koolaid.
I'm drinking it too.
I'm so into this.
Will wear that hat Saturday night.
So yeah.
Damn.
I'm,
I'm fascinated,
I'm fascinated by this fight.
I'm always fascinated when could be
fights because you're always wondering
like what's the first guy that's going
to be able to give him something
different?
See,
I look at it different.
I look at it like,
all right,
I hear all this crazy talk about could
be,
let's see it.
Like I wanna see,
I wanna see that pound for pound
greatness out of them.
Let me get it when you don't,
you think you saw it in the Barboza
fighting?
No.
I think Barboza is one dimensional.
I think,
uh,
I think we did see,
and I think people are taken for granted
how good could be both a grappler is,
cause you talked to Frankie talked to
Eddie Alvarez.
I go,
how hard is it take down Barboza they
go,
oh,
it's damn near impossible.
And Training.
Like we don't get them down very easily
and they're bad asses.
Right?
So you'll,
what could be did we didn't think he was
gonna be able to do.
And if you look at that third round,
Barboza is like,
he gets taken down and he's like kind of
cage crawling.
You look at his face,
he looks like get me the fuck out of
here.
Like there's sheer panic and that's the
difference drink could be and the rest
of these fighters,
that's why it's the worst of fight them
on short notice because it's not going
to be fast.
You know,
it's not going to be fun for you.
It's a smashing it.
I feel like the brain,
we've seen the pound for pound greatness
in him,
like the potential for it,
but we need to see him against pound for
pound greats.
Well that's how you get get there,
but you have to show up Connor Aldo.
Right,
right,
right.
That quick knockout or DC Gustin Jon
Jones,
DC,
like there are certain times in your
career where you have the signature
wins.
He doesn't have a signature win.
Right.
Well,
I think the Barboza is as close as you
can get.
But Barbara was his lost to a few guys.
He lost it.
Tony,
he got darks,
choked and plus cowboy.
Yup.
But he's also very one dimensional.
Yeah.
Phenomenal on the ground.
He's a good anti wrestler.
His strikings phenomenal,
but overall package and that that is the
difference,
right.
Is the really good guys always
threatened takedowns always threatened
submissions.
He just doesn't do that.
He,
he stands up and he's a specialist
standup,
but I mean standup is wicked and he's
got some of the best stand up in the
world for sure.
Uh,
in mma,
I mean Barboza so fast to such a
wonderboy barboza the write up there
during till,
yeah.
Darren till in wonderboy is going to be
a mug there.
Fucker.
How about wonder boy?
I saw a quote coming in here we goes,
who's been not that impressive there
until,
who is he?
I'm like,
did you learn nothing from the cowboy
fight?
Even I learned from that.
I talked to you,
I was like,
man,
why would calve we take this,
I don't really know who Darren till is
and then my inbox is flooded with shit
and even did until went off on me and I
look at my like,
oh my God,
this guy's a monster.
He's an animal.
Doesn't have a gorilla tattoo or
something.
Does he?
He's got gorillas all over is like uses
it and his screen name and twitter w
well,
he's a gorilla.
He's a credible ever pool is a bad
motherfucker.
Wonderboy who's rehabbing is thumps and
it's just like,
alright,
if you want this,
and then what happens if,
let's say wonderboy were to win,
which I don't think he is,
unfortunately.
Let's say I don't,
you think I'm on the sales team?
I just,
yeah,
I think there's this kind of Darren
[inaudible] Dick ride a little bit right
now.
Ron,
hard Dick Riding on Khabib till there's
a few guys.
DC always conroy's always brian or
Tayga.
I did ride mighty mouse for sure.
Yeah,
you do Dick,
right?
That guy.
I think he's been that way forever.
I think he's the best.
I mean,
that's fair.
He needs a guy is a challenge him.
Is He fighting?
So hudl again,
who I love,
so Hutto but it's like that.
Do you guys hate fucking money?
That shit's ridiculous.
I mean,
so who knows a beast?
No doubt about it.
And I love what so Hutto did,
uh,
against uh,
Wilson Hayes.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
This is like a different,
so who does it looks like a karate
champion.
Yeah.
Get all that.
Did you see what mighty mouse did?
You went right through him.
Oh,
you,
oh,
you're a black belt.
Cool.
He Jewish on bar and Bar and what he did
to,
so who does,
oh,
you like to clinch check these out to
the Olympics.
That's very cool.
Check this knee.
Ouncer needs the body as fat.
I grabbed him once,
just joking around playing.
He hit me in the body with a niece so
fast.
He was confusing.
It was a confusing.
Where'd that come from?
Like I go,
I go,
I got ya.
He turns out,
hey man,
that's not supposed to go that quick
like this supposed to be.
I see you move.
I get to think that this might come my
way.
Here it is.
No,
it was already there different before I
realized he was doing it.
He's so fucking fast.
Why did,
do we know why the tj fights aren't
going down?
Dude?
I don't know.
But that one bums me out that that is a,
that's a fucking gigantic super fight.
Like why wouldn't he take that fight?
Well,
first of all,
mighty mouse right now is rehabbing
shoulder surgery.
So it's going to be a while.
He was doing those,
you know that both thing.
They do that flexy thing.
He was doing some of those exercises the
other day on instagram.
I'm looking at him like,
okay,
that's a guy that's got like,
he's got some scar tissue to work out.
Like that's not,
that's not healed up.
Did he get surgery?
Yeah,
he got surgery.
So he's out for a little bit and Tj
probably doesn't want to wait.
I don't know if that's what the case is.
I don't know what the case is.
I mean,
shoulder surgery six months.
so you wait three months,
then you have a three month camp,
you know?
I mean if they wouldn't announce it yet,
right.
No,
I mean,
I don't even know.
You can't even say that because teaching
isn't going to harm.
You might not be able to go if you,
Matt Hume and mighty mouse are about as
smart as it gets when it comes to
preparation.
So there's no way they would take that
fight of his shoulder wasn't 100% any
fight and risk his legacy because he
loses that fight and was like told Ya
and they wouldn't go hard early to test
it.
They would let it.
We'll look at what Whitley's been out a
little bit because of his shoulder he
got,
yeah,
he was in here like right after he got
it.
He said he's going to heal up quick.
Yeah,
and he might prp all that.
Yeah.
He's going to do all the PRP.
You know this as much different
therapies.
Cryo I'm sure it was probably still
takes a while even with all our advanced
stem cell,
but not now.
He's forced to fight and I,
I see what the UFC is doing where they
do it.
Interim Belt tween Colbian dos Anjos
where the,
you know,
it's an interim belt.
So now woodley,
you literally have to fight the winner
of this jam.
Have to fight them.
It's a very sneaky,
may have a belt.
What are you going to do?
You want a super fight?
Nope.
This guy's a belt.
I get both sides here.
If it stills Angeles,
Los Angeles Beats Colby dos,
Santos,
lightweight champion,
now welterweight champion.
But to me it takes me,
right,
great.
You can have dos Anjos sitting there
with two belts on shoulders.
I mean,
and then what do you do with Dan until
let's say he,
for whatever reason,
walks through wonderboy,
which is,
you know,
tough to do but say walks through it,
which would lead,
you know,
struggled a little bit,
walks through him and one of boys,
the number one guy now dead until jumps
up to number one or is dose antral work
that way?
Because the ratings are fucking screwy,
man.
Sometimes I see a guy who,
a guy and then that guy who he beat is
still ranked ahead of him there a
nightmare.
All they are.
All the writings do now.
It almost hurts if you're a guy like
sean shelby or Dana trying to make these
matchups cause guy who's at fourth year,
Hey,
wanting to fight 70 he's like,
no,
he's seven.
I have nothing to gain from that.
Where before it was like,
Hey,
we want you to fight this guy.
He's a name,
he's on some fight,
win streak.
We don't know what ranking is,
but we know he's damn good.
So you guys were more willing to take it
now they,
nope,
he's seven.
What?
I want a number one.
Exactly.
I need three four you know?
Yeah.
That's weird.
It hurts us.
It's also weird like the UFC could just
did they just decide who's fighting.
I mean it's the whole thing.
The business is so interesting because
it's like they decide who's fighting.
They decide who's champion.
They decide,
Tony,
you're not champion anymore.
I'm going to strip yet.
It's like put it,
I fell.
I don't want this to happen.
Fox Studios,
I just do.
I twist my knee,
but he was working for the UFC when he
fell.
I mean he's doing his,
his obligations,
his press obligated.
It's very strange to strip him of a belt
when he never lost it.
And here's the longest winning streak
and then and mean,
but also you have no belt can because
there's no belt can be what's going to
take the belt.
They're going to make up a belt and then
calm or has the belt at 55 so what do
you do with that belt?
Well,
what they're planning on doing,
I believe,
and now they've kind of let the cat out
of the bag cause they said it's going to
be for the world lightweight title.
They were going to strip connor the
moment something happened,
like the moment the fight started,
that's when they were gonna Strip
connor.
Because if they'd stripped him
beforehand,
then what happens if Tony doesn't make
weight or something totally mixed out of
could be,
doesn't make weight,
then what the fuck?
Do you have a concern then you have
nothing.
I mean you already stripped him.
We're going to give it back to him.
You gotta give it back to them now if
you,
so if he wants to fight again now,
he's not the champion anymore.
The fuck kind of Shit is strange.
So they waited and the idea was to wait,
but now they're in a desperado
situation.
Strange Rato belt on the line.
That'll yet fucking April fool's.
April fool's day,
it happens.
I didn't believe a God damn word of it.
Jimmy Smits starts texting me.
I'm like,
fuck that dude.
I'm not falling for it.
Jamie texted me.
I'm like,
I'm not falling for it.
You texted me,
you go,
Bro,
it's April fools.
I'm like,
no,
but Dana,
I sent data,
released a video and he's listening.
I'm sure he likes a good April fool's
joke,
but what he likes more his money and pay
per view buys.
You can't honey dick.
The fans are like psych.
It's back on.
People are going to be pissed and it'd
be biased.
That's a good point.
I didn't buy it.
I still was like,
maybe it's just an elaborate pr scam.
I didn't even tweet about it until the
next day.
I know I was tweeting about other shed
people like,
what the fuck,
Bro,
this is go down.
You're not even tweeting about.
And like,
I'm not,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm gonna check it out.
I checked with you and then I checked
with,
uh,
Josh Thompson who works closely with,
could be,
and then boom,
there's my two main guys.
And I went,
all right Ariel,
that's all aerial tweet.
I'm like,
God,
he's like the journalist.
I'm a,
I'm an ass clown.
He's a legit journalist.
He is the credibility summit,
Bro.
Is this really goes,
I would never joke around like that,
Brendan.
I'm like,
he's right.
Well,
I went straight to his Jujitsu coach.
I called Eddie,
talked to him on the phone.
So an Eddie gave me the full rundown of
what happened with Tony.
It's like he saw somebody and he turned
to say hi to somebody,
didn't see some wires on the ground,
tripped over some wires,
and just blew his shit out.
And Eddie was on the podcast yesterday
and Eddie was saying that Tony wanted to
fight or day before yesterday.
Tony wanted to fight,
they wouldn't let him fight.
Yeah.
His,
his ligament is torn lcl around the
bone,
which is rare,
which is hard to do.
I don't want,
where's that one?
Lateral,
lateral whatever.
Collateral Ligament,
some shit.
Anyways.
But do you think,
uh,
it would,
if,
if it went tripping off that,
is that a freak accident or do you think
it would have went during the fight?
It's hard to say.
Oh,
I bet it was a freak accident,
right?
To associate lcl.
Yeah.
I mean,
the way they said it,
but first of all with Dana said was very
savage.
What'd he say?
Dana said,
uh,
he wears her sunglasses in doors.
That should happen to everybody that
wears sunglasses indoors.
That's the letter that the light have
your glory,
David quote.
Cause there's only two types of people
that wear sunglasses indoors.
Blind people and assholes.
It's true.
It's so true.
It's so joe are those weird thing man,
especially at night.
Like what are you doing so hard to see?
What is this?
What are you doing?
I've seen a guy in a club when I used to
go to clubs,
he does the glass on and then people
walk laid,
lift them up to look around and put it
back down and you can't see shit.
The biggest tools wear glasses sis to
fights who wear sunglasses and they sit
there with her fucking sunglasses.
Not like,
especially celebrities that do that.
It's like flurries do it.
It's like get it,
get a grip however we meet.
That's like when you know you fucked up,
you got two famous,
you have to wear sunglasses at a fight
that sit in the front row.
It's Sunglass and your boys are just
like,
no,
I like it man.
Yeah.
Where those indoor.
That makes complete sense.
It same if you were like a peacock coat
and your boys like that's all good.
I'm gonna Start Doing podcasts like dude
did that stresses me out for now.
That stresses me out.
Sam trip,
we did a podcast like this.
Did you say something?
What did you say something to them like
what are we doing?
And I put mine on.
I put mine on and we've done it before
with the sunglasses with NASA outfits.
That's hilarious.
Deleted.
Did our put,
did the fighter and the kid with
sunglasses.
I don't.
I go,
Bro,
you got to take the sunglasses off.
He goes,
my future's too bright.
I went,
Oh fuck mine too.
And the calendars.
Shit.
I'd have my sunglasses.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing.
Sunglasses.
That's a hilarious quote by Dana though.
Yeah.
Hilarious.
And especially considering how much
money he's losing on the team.
Can you imagine,
can you imagine getting a call that
close and be like,
what?
What keeps happening?
It keeps happening.
Does it happen to this Mac?
Tim's typing a bunch of time.
Lemme may God's like you morons.
I'm trying to do your favor.
Who was the most recent one where that
happened?
Where cyborg stepped in last minute.
This close.
Yeah.
So the last one,
Cyborg stepped in.
Who?
Oh,
that was Max Holloway Holloway.
But then there was the Ferguson won with
Khabib where Khabib's liver shutdown.
They had to take him to the fucking
hospital.
It was a bummer.
That was a bummer because this happened
a ton of times though.
It was the worst one.
Jon Jones do ufc 200 dc mayor the the
right,
literally the day before.
You're like,
what?
But I would if that's better for the UFC
shitty business either way,
but is it better for the UFC because
people,
we've always seen the hype or a bought
in and then like the next day like what
the f?
Where's John like,
oh yeah,
you didn't hear that.
Like does that help them more or does
this week at least that can promote a
little bit with Max Holloway,
you could promote a little bit with Max
Holloway and it's an interesting fight.
It's a very interesting fight.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those men that happened
to you.
Like what?
Which one was the Jon Jones dc one.
You'll see 200 and that will,
what was the,
the thing that John did,
which one was that?
Remember that the coq one B,
I think there's a coke.
Coke was,
he goes,
this was Dick Pills.
You remember these?
He was like,
hey,
we got strip.
We had to pull them from the card and
then DC financial and Silva.
That's right on like founders,
Anderson and then DC didn't when fans
that cause he just kinda yeah.
Yeah.
He just wants to fight.
He just wrestled him in his whatever.
It's still one the front kicked him in
the gut too and I think you heard him.
He has messed up.
Yeah.
But it happened in sports.
This,
this is what I think makes fighting so
great.
So great.
Max says opportunity that no one else in
the world in sports can have and then
you know,
then look at Canelo triple g in,
in combat sports.
This is what we deal with.
Yeah.
Canela it's a biggest fight of the year.
Biggest fight ever wants to see the
rematch of the year and then tainted
meat.
Do you buy the tainted me?
Absolutely not,
sir.
I've had many Tacos in Mexico and I am
not swole.
Yeah,
but you're not getting tested for trace
amounts of clenbuterol you don't know.
Maybe I have to go and Snitch,
come to my house just for the fuck of
it.
And just to dream.
I'm still in the testing protocol.
Interesting.
No,
I,
yeah,
maybe,
I don't know,
but I would see some sort of change.
But,
or even triple g's camp goes,
uh,
last fight he was on it.
What else is new now?
Why didn't you,
why do you think they said that?
He,
I don't know.
I'm sure.
Listen,
I'm sure Gonad he's been in there with
what?
Over full 500 people now.
400 people.
And you just said in his experience he
can tell who's on pds and who's not.
And he thought Canelo was,
do you buy that?
I do cause that a fighter as a fighter.
This guys I fought who I assumed were
okay,
but what about Woodlin?
A guy like Woodley,
he has tremendous genetic.
He's always been like that.
Always been like that.
But so it was canela no,
you,
you look at it.
He's gotten pretty swollen now.
He's getting older though.
So it could be that too.
He's just as you get older you,
but I'm more size.
Well the big one was manny.
Manny was the one that everybody was
always accusing.
And Man,
he was the first,
I mean manny went up eight weight
classes and kept his knockout piece,
fighting as a little boy and then just
was like crazy.
I mean,
and kept the knockout power.
True.
And most people thought that man,
he was on ped.
Correct.
And then they thought that man,
he got off pds when he fought Juan
Manuel Marquez and he got starched.
But he,
there's two,
there's two side of the story there.
He got off PDS and also found Jesus
Christ.
So he stopped going to the Strip clubs.
He stopped hanging out with girls,
but he stopped having fun and then got
serious about Jesus and got knocked the
fuck out.
Yeah.
Jesus saw Jesus.
And that Jesus is like,
listen,
if you want to be a savage,
you got to live like a savage.
He's like,
I'm not even advising this man.
Just do your thing.
Can I go take them steroids?
It's like,
listen,
I made steroids.
Okay.
Yeah,
it's,
I'm Cara God that wheat grass ain't get
help your son.
Yeah,
that's good for you,
but you need good.
But you need this too.
It depends on what you are.
I mean,
if you want to be 147 pound knockout
artist,
let me,
but Marquez was no,
a stranger to the,
uh,
just getting supplements.
No,
no,
no.
Well his,
they had the same strength and
conditioning coach.
When manny found Jesus,
his old strength and conditioning coach
went over to the dark,
wet matt and Mel Marcus.
He's always on the dark state on the
dark side.
That dude was always in the dark.
What was he going now?
Hey Bill.
Alex.
Oh,
Riza.
Yes.
Good call brother.
Yeah,
he knows his shit,
man.
He knows his shit and I don't know
whether or not he'd got anybody on pdds
or they're just blaming him now.
He knows his shit.
It's a strength and conditioning coach.
That guy.
Very,
very good.
I would have worked with them if I was
fighting.
I saw the stuff that he was doing with
wine.
My Mom Marquez.
I was like,
this guy is,
he's super legit and he brings those
guys up to like modern levels are
correct.
Not The old school shit.
It's some of the old school shit too.
To this day.
I think chopping wood,
that's all legit man.
Sledge hammers on tires.
I think it was good and I agree.
I think it's good to add in.
I think dead lifts all that stuff,
but I think you mix that with the new
wave of technology.
Now you got some,
well,
what,
what I was saying about nick curse on
and that Marvin Marinovich method,
it's all,
it's playas man.
Everything's like junk box jumps and
movement.
Yeah,
left right,
left,
right,
right.
You know,
curse on sits on.
Very interesting to me when I said like,
what do you think fighters are missing?
Most like strength condition wants to
that foot strength.
That makes sense.
Totally makes sense.
You know who's,
who's been on that ball since God,
since I've known him as Lauren Landau,
who I worked with in Denver.
Now,
he just got the Gig as the,
he's the head condition coach of the
Denver Broncos.
Wow.
But he was making us work out barefoot
for Avar even as football players.
Steve Maxwell was always on that too.
I was kettlebell workout.
So those guys who it's like,
oh,
this is all new.
And then you talked to like a lauren or
that Max will gather.
Uh,
we've been doing this for like 20 years.
You guys are just now finding out about
it.
Well,
so many people,
you know,
you see so many people working out with
like high thick ass running shoes that
are all spongy on the bottom.
Yeah.
It'd be one of them.
A lot of people do bad.
But you're not training for a fight
right now.
No.
But if you were,
you tried to optimize everything,
wouldn't you?
Yeah,
I used to wear those five a finger.
I would wear those to run.
I'd wear those on the track had,
were those during most of my stuff.
So now you just wear regular running
shoes for comfort,
regular running shoes.
And then w I had a knee problem.
I was putting so many miles on it.
Now I'm on a bike.
I got,
I got one this pelotons so those are
dope.
But it's been good.
Those are good because it's,
you could play along and go along with
the class.
Yeah,
it's cool.
I'll show if it's the answer do every
day,
but I like you.
I need,
I need to mix it up man.
I'm getting,
I'm just bored as fuck with working out.
So that co bike,
those are dope.
I want to get one of those in the crib.
Got Our bags.
But I like to waking up cause my mondays
and Tuesdays are a nightmare.
I have to be on set at 7:00
AM so I'm waking up at like five just
doing that Pelton for an hour if that
I'm off.
Oh that's good.
Yeah.
We're before I'd have to try and go to
the gym or I was missing my workouts.
It drives me nuts,
dude.
He helped to start the day with a sweat
and then I get going.
You know what?
Kick him on.
The versaclimber dues are a nightmare.
I went to the gym the other day and I
did 150 meter sprint.
At the end of the workout,
the trainer had me do 150 meter sprint
on their first climb.
You feel like passing out?
Holy Shit.
It's hard.
When you get off man,
like you're barely allowed them before.
Yeah,
but I haven't been doing it now.
I'm getting one in here now.
I May.
It might be the toughest thing as far as
cardio wise again,
Loren landow,
you still have even as football players
all the time,
and I was like,
what the fuck are we doing man?
This is awful.
Is by far.
He'd have these circuits and it always
end on that.
I remember everyone,
if he's like,
here's your circuit,
and then on versa,
some of the best athletes in the world
just like,
oh my God,
man,
what are we doing?
Yeah,
but that's what they do at this,
this gym that I've been working at,
he likes you to do a circuit and the
circuit,
you get on the versaclimber and you
sprint and it's,
you know how much time to get to 150
meters.
I've been doing a rose with my trainer.
Oh yeah,
I do that too.
I do wrote,
we get a thousand meter row and I'm
like,
what's a good time?
So we looked up the top times.
I'm like,
I think I'm top 300 in the world right
now.
A bit,
you know,
I got to do some work.
There was a big,
yeah,
there's big difference between top 300
and then the top hundred.
Yeah,
but dude,
you're top 300 in the world with a row.
With a rail.
Yeah,
look it up.
That's pretty fucking sweet.
It's all right.
I mean,
it's a row machine.
I'm the top 85 million.
I mean,
no,
you're the hold up.
You're the,
hold on,
hold on.
Let's just,
I that that was the humble brag,
but let's just be serious there.
You're the,
you're the hardest kicker ever.
On that Goddamn UFC machine.
Well,
I call it the Francis Machine.
I is a video of me doing 152 right.
Right now you only see the one that me
kicking it and with my jeans on and that
what got to one 35 stretchy jeans?
Yeah,
barbell jeans.
Basically.
PDS.
PDS,
like sweatpants,
man.
So I'm dude burned me,
burned me from the audience and he goes,
hey man,
how long did it take you to paint on
those genes?
And I went,
oh my goodness sir.
He just scorched me.
Theo bunk did me dirty,
brought weird clown on each other.
We'd clowning each other.
I said,
you look like an extra from the waterboy
setting.
He goes,
he goes,
no,
fuck.
I'm like,
he goes,
Bro,
you like you,
you look like you work at Nordstrom's
rack and you're a mechanic.
Like fuck.
He talking about,
he's so good.
He's on thing.
But that fucking pants,
man,
these pants are the shit.
These are different.
These right now I have on there similar,
they're called Mott and bow is a no,
those are good.
Those are like legit jeans.
They'd like more feel like jeans where
the barbell jeans,
like they look like jeans to touch them
and I go,
hey,
what's going on here?
Like sweat,
sweat pants on Sun.
No,
those are,
that's in a good company to Jacob.
But just so bind you up a little bit
more if you were trying to kick somebody
a little bit more.
So what did you do though?
Record setting.
Kick barbell jeans.
This is the,
I did the record on.
This is the record one.
That dos Anjos rump.
Let's see,
you saw my hill running man.
My ass is way bigger.
A lot of people have been complimenting
me on it.
Nothing wrong with a knife like that fat
belly though.
I'm so fat right now.
You are not fat for me.
One 52.
And what's the hardest?
I'm definitely fatter than I usually am.
I been cheating on my died way too much.
I hear you man sheet and wait.
You might.
Well it's also,
I can't,
there's certain things I can't do in the
gym right now and I got this man,
this dildo that I got here.
This is for,
uh,
you know,
I've Golfer's elbow.
I have this tendonitis on how this
thing,
fuck dude,
I've never had tendonitis before.
Have you ever had it?
Yeah.
Not Fun.
It takes forever.
Forever.
Like way more than a muscle.
I got PRP,
I got regena keen,
I got stem cells.
I had a bunch of shots.
This,
this Dildo I'm holding.
This helped me more than any of them.
Two weeks in two weeks.
This things helping dry needling.
It did seem like it should have fixed
everything.
What did the dry needling,
oh,
let me do that too.
I had dry needling where they used
electricity and these zapped it.
Pollster to do nothing for me.
It didn't help.
This helped.
This is cheap.
You buy it on Amazon.
It's called a theraband.
And what do you do with it?
And my friend Brian told me about this.
Callan,
no,
no.
Brian from um,
I'll give you his last name.
He's vinny shoreman,
his buddy from um,
Fontana,
California.
I think.
What does this his thing?
Double Deuce Moitai is that his,
uh,
his place here?
Hold on.
Sorry.
It's a great shirt.
By the way.
Jamie,
Brian Doppler and Brian is a great Muay
Thai coach himself.
So when he do,
he had,
he had a issue and he told me this is
the thing that fixed him.
You take it,
you hold it out like this right in front
of you,
right?
Then you twist,
this is the arm that's injured,
the bottom arm.
So you hold out,
you twist it,
what the other one,
and then you hold it straight and then
you let it untwist with this arm slowly.
And I've been doing this shit all the
time.
I do it in my car,
I take it with me at home,
but I'm twisting the shit out of it and
then slowly untwisting it with my right
side to helping out too.
And it makes a big impact.
It makes a big impact because it's
strengthening it,
strengthening this,
this little particular area,
but it's also getting a ton of blow.
You hold it like that,
like palm palm out and then twist it
right and now straightened out.
Now unwind it with this hand with the
injured hand.
There you go.
Yeah.
And you just do that slow and I'll do
that for like five,
10 minutes of time and then I'll leave
it alone.
Game come back,
game changer.
All that other dude a lot better.
I mean obviously I've had a lot of other
shit done to it.
Like the Regena keen was like uh,
might help a month or so ago.
I'm sure it helped,
but that's good.
This once I started doing it almost
immediately within a few days.
So you're feeling better basics then?
Yeah,
but I can't,
there's a lot of shit I can't do.
Like I can't do chin ups right now.
Have been able to do chin ups.
I could do rows,
but I can't go have you then like 50
pounds.
Like everything has to be all about
preserving this little ligament.
And your trader knows that.
Yeah.
This is a new trainer.
As long as they're a good trade as they
usually know how to adapt.
But even here,
like when I'm training here,
he can't do it with so much shit I can
do and can't do anything on the rings.
No,
no.
I can throw straight punches,
but no,
no,
no hooks,
uppercuts.
But it's getting,
it's getting much better just in two
weeks of using this fucking thing.
Everything.
Thinking about resting it maybe just not
doing amy thing sir.
Mm.
That's how I got fat.
Well,
you could,
you could still get up.
You're crazy.
For me to stick on a diet,
I have to add to uh,
have a meal specialist,
like delivering my meals on that guy
right now.
I'm usually really good at it,
but,
but one thing this has done is ramped up
my hill running.
So I've been doing just go,
oh,
are you the type of dude thought,
well how we see late night.
You're always posting,
you know,
you got that Fedex.
I would see when Ph vet,
I see when a at night when you come home
from the comedy store,
you always posting like protein and
veggies.
Are you really eating that or are you
like,
there's that and then you have a
Mcdonald's on the side?
I'm not saying Donald.
If I cheat,
it's pasta of dude.
That was me last a whole pizza the other
day.
I can give it up buller from,
it was at a restaurant.
I worked with the,
with the misses and we ordered some
other stuff and I said,
let's just get a pizza too.
Right?
That's how it's done.
She's like,
I'm not really into this.
I'm like,
good for her.
That's me,
man.
I walked the whole pizza down eight,
that whole fucking,
I'm so disappointed in myself.
I had these,
I had these meals,
man,
I've,
I've been strict on it.
When I'm on the road,
it's fucking tough.
Or when if I might get an sleep,
my buddy crave sugar and carbs,
but I always say,
and I'm like,
I just want,
and then one,
I just can't stop myself.
It's hard.
And then last night,
my,
my son this pasta,
and of course I have to try it.
I'm gonna make sure it's not poisoned.
And I tried it.
I'm like,
that's fucking way better than my meal
that they eat.
So I just fired up some Tortellini.
It's hard.
It's also hard when you work hard
because I wore,
I do a lot of things.
I'm always busy and it's like sometimes
it just want to go off with food.
Like that's my indulgence.
That's the one thing that I can get
loose on men,
but most of the time I'm very strict
most of the time.
But it's been hard with this injury,
it's just because I thought it was going
to be healed by now,
so it's been frustrating.
The shit out of me.
There's certain things I want to do.
Like I was on this heavy chin up kick
and heavy cleans and presses kick and
that's probably where I want to do this
because I felt some twinges instead of
just working on it and like letting it
heal up,
push through it for months.
That's the athlete in you.
That's the idiot in me for months.
I pushed her,
but that's how it works.
When you're an athlete,
I'm sure when you're doing taekwondo or
Jujitsu,
you get hurt.
It's not like,
oh,
let me take months off to make this bed.
It's none of that.
Yeah.
That,
and that's what Eddie said about Tony is
it like Tony when he gets hurt and he's
like,
whatever I'm hurt just works around it.
Whatever it is.
He doesn't stop working out ever,
ever.
Yeah.
But this is a,
an eyeopener for me.
This,
this theraband thing is like always keep
searching.
There's,
Oh,
and another thing I have is this other
thing that I put my fingers in this
rubber thing and I expand my fingers,
right?
Because it's very difficult to expand.
You know,
it's easy to contract.
You're always doing that.
But how much strength do you have this
way?
Very little.
It's kind of shine.
Do you ever do it?
Never.
But this rubber thing is really good and
I think I read,
I think it was jim still panty who's a
bodybuilder guy online.
He's got a bunch of supplements and Shit
and uh,
he's a,
he's also super,
super smart,
educated guy and he,
he was recommending that for people with
tendonitis.
There's a lot of different things you
could do with bands.
And this one,
this is the strongest ones they have to
shaking like a dick.
Do you rubber Dick?
Do you think if you would've went to a
physio therapy,
they would have shown me all this stuff
before he injected yourself with all
these needles and stuff.
I feel like that a lot of it's physiol
maybe.
Yeah.
No,
you live,
you learn.
Most of them were just saying ice it and
rest.
It was like damn the wrath.
Yes,
but the rest of they want,
it's just not what I want to do.
Yeah,
the ball.
It's also when your body is so used to
going hard and then going hard and then
your body to start.
Okay,
let's find some problems.
Let's go sit still.
And it's like one,
I'm lazy and they feel like a bitch.
I know but like I said,
it's increased my butt.
Donka donk ens.
Aw man to the missus likes it or she
wants you to tone it down and she's
happy with it.
No one likes a flat ass.
No one likes vanilla guy.
Yeah,
no one.
That might be the worst thing.
You feel flat and I want to grow a small
deck and slap girl wants a flat ass
cause she knows the guy is not going
anywhere.
Correct.
Yeah,
look at it.
Look at him when it's flat.
Flat Ass fucking shitty.
Gene loafers on.
Don't see loafer Gucci loafers.
No socks gets tired.
Walking upstairs to imagine if all of a
sudden you had someone's flat ass and
then you had to like walk around and you
gotta realize,
Oh my God,
it's so hard to walk up hills.
How to get around,
get around flat out carrying up the
grocery bags up the stairs.
That's out.
How about when you you,
I've seen it where it might one of the
easiest muscles to build.
Like there's some girls with flat asses.
Then you see them on instagram.
These instagram models who do like dead
lifts or something and then just over
time boehm that ash just grows like a
tomato.
If they really are motivated,
you can get your ass to grow.
Little Winnie,
little fucking little of that for sure.
There's a lot of that going on with
girls,
man.
There is when straws,
what we're talking about folks who don't
know what when I wasn't referring to
Winnie the Pooh,
I'm talking about when Straw.
Yeah.
A lot of those fitness girls are doing
steroids.
They just do a little bit,
just a little bit,
just a little bit changes in Maranhoa
bit.
The jaw.
You look at the shoulders,
they get badly,
need time to anytime counts.
He's a rip curl,
use steroids and literally everything
stare writes my God damn Bro.
That shit though.
They keep it.
That's what's weird to keep the manly
parts like the,
like they don't just keep the muscles
when they get off the shit.
If their face is still hard.
Yeah,
they're structured like their face
structure's a little different.
As a lady who lives in my neighborhood,
she used to be a big Ole Miss Olympia
and see her walking around and it's
weird.
She's,
she's,
she's looks like a man,
not just in her face,
but in her,
her,
the way she carries herself everything.
Right.
So like,
you know,
I mean that sounds weird to say,
but there's a certain masculine quality
that the,
the people,
the women that take massive amounts of
steroids,
they develop.
They just develop the,
they looked different.
They will,
they're wider.
Yeah.
They don't look like they're going to
take care of you.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't,
I'm not attracted to that.
I don't know.
Listen to each other.
Sweet.
That I can be the best moms.
What I'm saying,
it's like it's not,
that's a,
that's even bad.
But it's,
but if you want that,
I'll stop those.
Career woman will be mad at you.
Like if you want a soft,
if you want a soft,
sweet,
caring woman who likes to cut on,
it's going to be a good mom and it's
just sweet to be around.
You mean the opposite of us?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But a lot of career women will get mad
at you.
I know.
Like,
Oh,
is that true?
Do you want,
do you want a woman to just can't take
care of her salary?
You don't want it to be equal.
No.
Badge.
I Day Brian Callahan.
I'm good.
I talked to week,
I'm Brian.
If I wanted that.
Well that equals stuff.
It's like equal.
How?
How's how?
Oh,
you just can't date your equal.
You Go,
you go date some cartoon.
Like all right.
Okay.
But they want to be a woman in some
respect.
Right.
They don't want to be an equal,
they're not claiming they're like,
is strong as you or as funny as you or
is know as much about pussy.
The good thing,
where are you equal?
You're not an equal,
you're a woman.
You're just,
uh,
you're just,
an aggressive,
successful,
powerful woman,
but cause you,
but you're not a man.
Like if you were an equal,
I'd be gay.
Correct.
Would be two dudes like high five and in
buttfuck game together,
that's fine.
That's cool.
But like this whole one,
an equal like why do we have,
why are we playing math games?
Yeah.
Why can't we just be chill?
Can we just like each other?
Why do we have to be equal?
What is that?
I don't know.
It's weird.
Women I have run from it.
He so successful.
Who,
who,
who was it who said there can only be
one headshot and household and we heard
that.
That's good though.
You can only have one head shot in the
household.
It's not going to work out if you both
want to be famous.
You know,
George Harrison once said,
he said,
um,
all I need from a woman is to be
attracted to her.
Everything else I get from a man,
it's a great quote.
Wow.
We're going to get shit for that.
Well,
what do you say that I didn't say it.
No,
I would never say that.
I would not either.
I would,
I knew with any knew all equal,
I mean equal,
right.
Equal pay the rent a bitch and I need
someone who calls me on my shit and
yells at me all the time and throws
things out and even makes fun of me.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what I want.
That's exactly what just comes home with
a six vacuum rips a huge fart.
Okay.
This female bodybuilder,
candice Armstrong steroid habit made her
grow a penis and facial hair.
Whoa,
that's,
she's a dude.
Well.
Sure.
That's real.
She's on that Gold's gym.
Dial.
What?
See the Dick?
Come on.
Whoa.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
See she turned into a man.
Oh Wow.
And the heavy whitehead.
That's a giant white.
So white must've.
They must've put makeup on her too.
How are they letting that whitehead go?
That staff,
why wouldn't they cover that up to she's
so jack later.
Her hands.
Oh my God.
Look at her arms to,
she should say's that's a dude.
That's a dude.
Come on.
Is this a joke?
It was my be a judge like criss angel.
She doesn't even look like that.
Yeah,
but w the sides of her hands looks
proportionate to it.
She doesn't look like a girl that ships.
There's nothing feminine about that
woman.
Look at her back.
Holy Shit.
Look at those backpacks.
Sure,
sure.
Oh my God.
That's photo shoot.
That's a dude with a nice set of here.
Well,
some girls can be jacked and muscular,
but still look like a woman like felice
herrick.
Do you see felice herricks?
She's fighting this odd.
Oh,
she's bought it up.
But you see the picture of her do a
double biceps from the back.
Some pictures she did at the UFC.
Preston,
you like Cha tractive young lady.
There's a few who are jacked.
He would attract.
She's jacked,
but she's Jack like a woman.
She Jack like a woman who lifts weights.
Yeah.
It doesn't look great.
Official.
No.
This lady that we just saw.
Yeah,
that's a good picture.
But that's just her looking fit.
There's a,
there's a picture of her.
Just Google,
like her image double bicep or something
like that.
She's a lady.
She's not tracking that lady.
See it,
but she shreds city Sun.
That's a shredded fit woman.
But there's that looks like a woman,
like look at her arms.
It looks like a powerful woman's arm
who's in shape.
His balls as shit and shape is fuck.
But that other lady that didn't
[inaudible] I didn't mean in shaping the
balls.
Get Shit online.
She's a tank fire shop.
He said balls.
Yeah,
we can't fire for your own thing.
If they fire you from showtime,
you'll,
it'll be like they use the force against
themselves would just make you stronger.
I do see a lot of crazy shit though.
He could do that show on your own.
You can do all or anything like that you
could do on your own.
Yeah.
I think it's great that you're on
showtime.
It's a fun show too.
Yeah.
What I like about it is you're being you
on that show.
Yes,
I see you on that show.
I'm like,
oh,
they let him be himself.
Like you say about your silly shit
laughing.
There's a lot of cracking ops.
Yeah,
I have fun.
They let me do my thing.
The first one,
it was like,
there's a lot of teleprompter and I was
like,
God,
that's really not my thing yet.
Let me go.
And they listen to me.
That's the great thing about showtime.
They listened to me,
but the fans like,
man,
this isn't why we listened to Brendan to
be another fricking sports show.
Like you gotta let them go.
And then literally they all were like,
all right,
here you go,
man.
Here's your point.
Do what you want to do.
I'm like,
really?
But then they edit it so I don't get in
trouble.
Like,
oh my God,
which is why they're showtime and um,
what I do,
well that means this were we we talked
about the other day with Eve Edwards.
He was in here.
That was,
that's one of those things like,
and I was saying when you talk as much
as we talk,
we bought,
I talked too much.
You talk too much.
We talked too much.
Yes.
When you talk too much shit comes out of
your mouth.
You guys step in some shit and then
you're scrambling and trying to like
make it
since Joe [inaudible] I can't,
I didn't listen to the podcast with
these.
I like these,
we don't know each other that well.
The thing that bothers me about this is
I couldn't even tell you the point I was
trying to make as soon as I give us $1
million.
Tell us the point you're trying to make
money.
I forget.
I remember had Kevin Leon and then I
remember before that I was 20 minutes
deep and explain why think dc the
greatest of all time as a beside you as
a commentator,
why is the future of the sport?
And then before that show,
me and Brian were talking about
something with race and men and women
and somehow that entered my brain and I
have no animosity toward it this way.
It does make sense.
I have no animosity towards UFC tonight.
Two of my favorite shows.
I've worked with Karen Bryant for over
10 years.
She's a good friend.
Woodley DC,
Kenny Florence,
good friend.
Bisping's a good buddy.
Uh,
I don't know,
ease.
I work with the team on UFC light.
I love those guys.
I just had Jimmy Smith in and on my show
who works,
you know,
there it does,
it makes zero sense.
And then I was in Saint Louis and I
started to get texts from so involved in
that show.
I won't say their name and he goes,
hey man,
some people are upset here about what he
said.
And I'm like,
what?
I see.
I can even tell you what I said.
And he tells me like what?
And then Chin goes,
hey man,
I'm seeing online about some of the
stuff you should I edit it out?
No,
we never do that again.
Don't edit.
Let me deal with it.
Let me see what I say.
Cause that makes me look even worse.
If you cut it out,
it looks like I was saying something
that I wasn't meant to say.
And uh,
then you know,
eve's was upset and then me and eve's
texts back and forth again.
I don't know him.
Brian works with them.
A little bit uncertain stuff for help or
something like that for shows where
we've tried to do,
which is great.
Everyone should talk to Brian,
you know,
if you're friends with them.
And then,
um,
I sent you a text says number from Brian
and I thought it was over squashed.
And then,
uh,
I was doing pr for my,
below the belt show in New York and
someone brought it up.
I'm like,
oh man.
Again,
I went and I met,
no offense,
I come up with about 10 hours of content
a week.
I can tell you what I was saying.
I messed up.
Um,
whoever had problems with it,
if it's Eve Edwards,
um,
that's his own insecurities,
which is so stupid because I couldn't
tell you what he should be insecure
about.
That makes sense.
And then as soon as I get done that I
interview,
I get texted,
my brother is this,
he goes,
you're an idiot.
You resurface that story.
I'm like,
oh my God.
And so I texted him again and then comes
on here,
right.
And then I haven't listened to it.
And then,
uh,
you know,
I texted,
he's like,
dude,
I don't want to keep going through this.
I meant zero fence.
I've texted Karen Bryant,
DC Woodley,
literally anyone you'll see tonight,
I this business,
especially in entertainment,
you know,
better anyone,
it's impossible to be successful in this
business.
It's a fucking monster.
I'm,
I'm willing to help them out.
I want the help.
You know what I'm saying?
I,
I don't want to criticize people.
That's not what I do.
That's not what I signed up for this.
I just got caught on a path when you
started talking about,
yeah,
and then one of the things that we do,
the best part about it is there's no
script.
The best and the worst.
It's the worst because I could deal with
this.
Sometimes he goes haywire.
Yeah,
but it ain't go haywire.
My biggest issue is,
is whenever someone was hurt by my words
or,
or does it upset by something I said,
then I'm like,
I again,
I don't know Eve's that well at all,
but I lost sleep over.
I'm like,
oh my God,
what am I doing?
I have respect for him.
He's a pioneer at one 55 again,
I love all the people you've seen
tonight and I've watched the show all
the Goddamn time there.
My friend just went to 0 million cents
duck and you,
you tried to just make sense of your
words.
It makes no sense.
I Apologize Steve.
It's,
it's all good.
I told him,
open door policy ones come on the show
we can talk about on there,
but I put my foot in my mouth and I hate
to tell you it's right and happen again.
I wish I could say it's not,
it's probably happening again.
It's part of what makes it fun is that
you are really working without a filter.
Working without a net.
You're just,
you're trying to have fun.
So yeah,
I mean that's,
sometimes you just take some swings and
you miss things.
I,
I came to ball,
I was trying to hit,
I came to tell you I was taking swings
at balls.
I was,
even though it was hitting.
So sometimes that shit happens,
but it happens.
Yeah.
It's just one of those things.
I mean,
I've done it a hundred times in this
podcast,
said some shit and I'm,
I was like,
what the fuck did I even say that for?
I don't even know what was going on in
my mind.
And sometimes like when you're trying to
form a sentence,
like right now I'm trying to form a
sentence,
right?
Like,
sometimes while you're thinking about
it,
you're like,
this isn't going so good.
I know.
Let me try to make it sound better.
All right,
let me try to see if I could rescue this
for the people that are listening and
make some sense.
And then it just makes it more clout and
more,
fuck.
It's hard for people to fall.
And you was like,
oh my God,
I speak for a living,
have ever been on stage.
He was going through my set and I was,
I've been doing it so much lately.
All be in the middle of it.
And in my mind,
I'm fat forward to already the next bit.
And I'm thinking about that bit while
I'm doing this.
One of you had done that or am I curious
about that?
I know cause I'm not,
I'm not present.
Don't do that.
And you know what happened is I missed I
s I skipped over a part that was new and
I thought it was gonna be a home run.
I skipped over it.
Yeah.
And I went back and because I record it,
right.
And,
um,
and I didn't realize I was doing the
moment.
And I listen,
I go,
oh my God.
And I remember in my head going,
dude,
you're here on third.
You're in first base.
You're looking at third already.
You Miss Second Pace.
You're not even,
you're not even the moment.
That's hard because there's like a,
you never know how you should think when
you're on stage.
You're doing the bit and you're just
trying to perform the bit,
right?
And if it's going well,
then you start thinking,
okay,
this is going well.
What am I going to lead into next?
But while you're still talking about
originally you can't do that.
I know.
Have you done that before though?
My ap?
Yeah.
No,
I've definitely done it.
He was so disappointed in myself,
man.
The big thing about comedy,
one of the big things is the audience
has to know that you are honestly
thinking about that subject.
Like even if you've talked about it a
hundred times when you're talking about
it that day in front of those people
they want,
they,
they're hearing it for the first time.
They want you to be tuned into that
subject.
100% of present.
Yeah,
if you're not,
they can sense it.
I know.
I was so disappointed.
I've never done it before.
And it was,
it was very strange too because,
and this is what hurts me about the eve
Edward situation is the guys I looked up
to yourself,
Gary Shandling,
like they always help people,
man.
You don't put anyone down.
They always help people.
And I don't have the same platform you
guys have,
but I like to think one day I will.
And I want to help people like you guys
help people.
Like there's the 60 degrees of
separation and you look at all the lives
you've touched and Garry shandling,
it's,
it's insane.
That's so inspirational to me.
And I was watching the Garry shandling
doc.
I went,
man,
that's so cool.
And that's why this Edwards situations
fucking me up.
Cause I'm like,
damn man,
it's not,
I don't want to hurt anyone.
But with back to the comedy,
I was so excited because the garry
shandling stuff,
when they,
whenever they Kay Shanley,
whenever they show comedy store stuff,
it's just,
I'm so into it,
man.
He was talking about the comedy store
and I got super inspired and I was like,
let's do this.
I'm never been more pumped to hit the
stage.
And then that happened.
I was so disappointed.
You're,
you're still getting it.
I mean,
think about like how long you've been
doing standup.
He'd been doing it less than two years.
Yeah.
This is a thing that's going to come up
and it's like,
you know,
it's like,
uh,
like when you're,
you know,
you're doing a certain move and you'll,
you'll leave yourself open for an arm
bar,
you know,
like,
how the fuck am I still doing that?
It's just,
you just have to submit it into your
head.
It's a craft,
you know what I mean?
You're,
you're,
you got a great work ethic and you're
funny dude,
and you're,
you're very good at going off the cuff
and you're impulsive.
Like those are all great qualities for
comedy.
And you also doing the work and to
involve like you're listening to tapes,
you going over notes,
you're doing things.
A lot of comics don't do,
cause a lot of comics are fucking lazy.
Like I've had conversations with dudes
and like,
Hey,
you did a fucking special last August or
last October and you're already
recording another one.
And I'm like,
yeah,
I work,
I fucking work.
Like I really work.
Like I get home from a comedy store,
I'll get home,
it's 1230 at night.
I'll just sit in front of the fucking
TV.
I'll put something on just for
background and I pull out the laptop and
I start writing when he come back from
the semester.
Right.
I go over,
I go over subjects,
I'll put a,
I mean sometimes it just have something
in the background just for a visual.
I just like to be stimulated by
something back.
Or sometimes I'll just sit by myself at
my desk.
Just nothing,
just nothing but that fucking screen
staring at it.
And when I do that every two or three
days I'll come up with a great line.
Yep.
Every two or three days,
which is nuts.
What's his nuts,
which is a lot of work.
Yeah.
And cause usually I'll come home late at
night,
I'll just take one little hit to sit
down and go over the is give those ideas
their time.
You're the stuff you already have.
Give those ideas their time.
And then maybe I have a new idea,
maybe of a new idea.
I'll flesh that out too.
And then I'll come back and look at that
again tomorrow night.
And then I have a whole list.
I started using this program called
scrivener.
You ever heard of scrivener ipad?
Uh,
well you can use it on Mac.
Um,
it'll work on an ipad or you could use
it on a windows too.
Um,
I've been writing on windows I write on.
I liked that.
I like actual paper,
uh,
papers.
Good.
But I can't write with my hands as fast
as I can type the phone version.
Oh,
they've got a phone version two.
Is that for Android as well?
It says features for Ios.
So what exactly do you do with this job?
Um,
well this one is,
this is different show the corkboard
thing,
the corkboard things.
Interesting.
Um,
what,
what they do is just see if you could
yeah,
right there.
Pull that up.
So they have it like this.
This is like,
you could do it in different colors.
So you gotta have different,
each one of those things.
Those little windows can be like a box.
Oh,
that's cool that you know that that
doesn't look like a cork board.
But sometimes you can,
you could change the background and shit
and make it actually look like a cork
board.
But what it is is basically a board,
a bulletin board where you've taken an
index card and you put it up there in
the index card has the subject that's
sweet.
So do that in real life too.
I have a real cork board and I put index
cards on the Cork Board.
Like if I'm doing like Vegan cat,
I'll do that bit.
I'll put it up right there that says I
can't wait for that one.
And I put all these different things on
the cork board and then I'll look at
them and I'll pick one and then I'll do
it if it really,
all these different things.
It's just about making the time,
making the,
putting the focus.
That's what you do and that's why you're
getting better so quick and all these
are the guys like,
what the fuck?
Here's where we're doing an hour.
What the fuck he touring the road.
He works,
he listens to those recordings.
Nobody listens to the recordings,
man.
They record them and they never listened
to them.
I listen.
You gotta listen half too.
It sucks to hear your voice,
right?
It's not good.
They're the worst.
That's what it looks like.
Oh,
that's sweet man.
So it's set up like that.
I like,
we're literally looks like,
so I have that on my laptop and so I
come home,
I'll,
I'll pause to open a card and I'll pick
a subject and I'll start going and if
something else comes to mind while I'm
on that,
I'll just start talking about that and
just keep going.
It's all just about opening up the flood
gates,
but really just about giving,
giving everything more time,
giving everything more,
more attention,
your focus,
you know,
and not just skimming through it and
it's over done.
What's good is a moment like this where
you fucked up and you were thinking
about one bit while you're thinking
about another,
now you know that that can happen.
Yup.
So that's like a lesson.
So just look at it as a good thing.
Like now you're set,
we'll be stronger because of that.
Whenever I have a bad set,
the one good thing that it says to me,
it's like,
okay,
I know how bad that feels.
I know where I went wrong.
I know it live comedy man live is crazy.
It's just,
there's so many factors.
It's so,
it's so loose and wild.
It's just,
it's a crazy way to perform.
You know?
And sometimes it doesn't go right,
but purest way to perform.
Yeah.
I mean,
but everyone I know like as far as who's
just the tip of the spear as French
comedy,
like you bur Deleah went,
there's one thing in common.
All you guys work,
man.
Gotta work relentless.
Constantly.
Got to be doing sets all the time.
You know,
I'll do sets three,
four nights a week,
um,
at the,
at the least a good week.
I'll do five,
like wrapping up from my special,
I'll do five and your specialty.
Yeah.
It,
uh,
Wilbur Boston.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
20th and 21st can't wait man.
Great.
Is that room the best?
That room is crazy.
Right?
And for me that yet I highlight that one
like as far as lifetime achievements,
the Wilbur for a guy like me to sell it,
the Wilbert Wyatt and then you open and
we kept it a secret.
I'm a chatty cathy.
I was so proud of myself.
That was great.
Good Beth man.
Well also that place is like three
comedy clubs.
Yes.
It's like there.
Everyone's so close to you,
even though it's like 1100 people,
1200 people,
whatever it is.
They're stacked up so close to you.
It's like 500 on the bottom and then
yeah.
You know what it's like that in the
fight world is the poems.
Yeah.
When I thought Roy,
I was like,
God,
get off of me man.
Get out of town.
I didn't like it.
The palms was great.
Yeah,
pumps is great.
They're not doing it anymore,
right?
No,
I think doesn't Lorenzo on the palms
now?
Didn't they buy the palms?
Yeah,
they did.
Yeah.
Hashtag Bolan taken over.
Yeah,
because the 27 casinos just isn't
enough.
Like now let's keep it going.
Yeah.
They own all those station casinos.
Those fuckers are everywhere.
Stayed at Olin,
don't I stayed at,
they made me stay at that Palestinian
casino when I was getting,
before I went in on the ultimate
fighter,
the worst whole diversity
of my life.
Really the worst.
The worst.
Hands down.
I've never seen the hotel.
Now at the time is under construction is
off the strip and of course there's a
hooker.
Been smacked around the other room.
I've told this story when I thought
there was,
I was going to be a captain,
save a hoe and they get pulled out a
gun.
I ran my underwear almost got kicked off
the ultimate fighter.
I've told this story on here,
I think,
but that's power station casino guy
pulled a gun on you.
Well,
uh,
it was the night before,
the ultimate fighter,
right?
Sorry if you've already heard this.
It was the night for the ultimate
fighter.
And they,
they put all the fighters in there and
they tell you the production staff goes,
do not leave this room.
If you leave this room,
you will be kicked off the show before
even begins.
You're not allowed to leave this room.
We're taking your phone.
Everything all you have is what you
bring in the house.
Do not leave this room.
We'll bring you food,
any food you want,
call down.
So I called had myself Nice Caesar Salad
Cause I worried about my finger on the
ultimate fighter and the next day and
uh,
I finally fall asleep and I hear this
arguing next door and the walls are
paper thin.
It's pallet station for God sakes.
And I hear this guy in this girl arguing
like it's waking me up.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And then she's just going off and I hear
him slap the piss out of her.
Oh,
I'm like hard.
And then there I hear keep going and him
hit her again.
I'm like,
Aye man.
So I'm like fuck this.
So I get up in my underoos to like stop
this because I just thought it was a
regular dude hitting a girl.
I'm like,
I'm not flying.
I'm not cool with that man.
I get up and salt,
I get on my door and I hear another do
go,
Nah man,
fuck this bitch.
I'm going to shoot her.
And I hear a gun clock,
Amal.
Uh,
definitely not going in there now.
Fuck that noise.
And I'm like,
God,
it's so quiet.
I'm like,
I don't want him to hear me.
So I'm army calling my undies the door
cause I'm afraid fucking gunfire.
It's going to go off.
I get to my door and I hear him go,
hold up dog.
Hold up someone's next door.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
So you'll see that,
I'm sure there's video of this power
station,
me just booking down the hallway and I
run to the casino and the,
the staff was like,
game when something,
they see me go running by and went to go
get security or underwear in my
underwear and I went to go get security.
But all the production staff saw me and
they're like,
what the fuck is shop doing?
So I told,
I'm the k,
some girls are about to get shot next
door.
I don't know what's going on.
But she was hip before.
There's two dudes in there and there's a
lady in my room,
two 13 and like,
all right,
so you'll show us.
So I go up there,
I'm not there,
it's there.
And then they just,
they go,
go to your room.
But I'm in my room,
like look and see what's going on.
And like a whole crew of them go in
fucking the girl starts defending the
dude attacks.
Security.
They have to taste the dude,
the other guy who was going to shoot
her,
they put in handcuffs and it's too
large,
you know,
black dudes.
And I'm like,
I'm like fuck this.
So they bring me down the hallway cause
just in case is going down,
they're bringing down the hallway,
but I'm like this with the crew and I
hear the guy go,
I see you white boy fucking snitch.
We'll be back and we'll ah,
so that,
and I was like,
can I get another room that I know that
there's no more rooms?
I'm like,
well they know where I'm staying,
man.
I'm supposed to start a show tomorrow.
Like what this is.
I mean,
what do you want us to do?
And like anything else.
And I had to stay and I got zero zero
winks of sleep,
literally zero Shiro Mesh.
I was so scared.
And that's more than when they knocked
as like,
yes,
I'm here.
Put me in the ultimate fighter house.
Yeah,
that guy got out of jail like quick or
guarantee.
Oh for flapping up and it,
she was a prostitute.
I did not know that,
but still eat the pimp.
It was a pimp and a prostitute.
She then some John is in that.
She's a woman.
She's my equal.
She's your equal.
I like how are you?
Thank you.
Think you're a feminist.
Ah Man.
That's where I can turn this into that
stuff and as a joke,
that's just showing your belly.
I know,
man.
This whole me too movement and it's,
I dunno.
It's a tricky situation.
It is.
You think is going to bounce back.
I think the game's changed for forever.
I do.
I think if you're a creep,
you can get sought out and found out.
However,
I think men in power and position and if
there's an attractive young lady in the
office or the studio,
there's,
this is always to be the dynamic because
I think there's,
I think there's some attractive young
ladies out there who are like,
I don't have a problem with it.
They did?
Yeah.
Okay.
He's an attractive dude.
Just happens to have some power and get
me a movies whenever,
but actually like him,
you know,
I'm not being forced to do this.
Well there's,
there's a new option now.
It's almost like a new element is in the
game.
Like if you're playing a game and then
all of sudden someone found like a new
magic power,
you can end careers now if you are like
a woman who was sexually abused by a guy
like Harvey Weinstein used to just have
to take it.
Now you have a new power,
which is all about.
However,
some will take advantage of that power
and pull that card when it's not real
and dudes are losing their jobs.
Like,
whoa.
Yeah.
There's people that are crazy,
like,
look,
that video that we were watching before
the podcast today,
or that lady was shot up youtube,
we're watching her,
her online videos,
one of the worst youtube videos I've
ever seen.
She's fucking nuts and there's going to
be people like that and there's going to
be people like that that take advantage
of the me too movement.
It's just,
it's just going to be,
I mean,
there's no way you can deny that there's
just a part of human nature that's with
anything though,
right?
Yeah.
But ultimately where it's going to shift
as people have to be nicer to each other
and they can't get away with shit like
that,
and that's what Weinstein was doing was
nothing but crime.
It's just crying.
He's a bad dude.
He's a bad dude and I'm glad that
happened.
Yeah,
I really am.
I'm glad he got sought out and he's
scrutiny should be screwed.
You imagine being a chicken,
you have to suck that fat guy's Dick nor
to getting a movie.
Hey Harvey,
he's there amy way.
You could just look a little more
attractive now.
Do you have to be so hideous?
There's nothing you can do at this
point.
They would have to cut chunks of his
face and pull it back to kids.
The money.
He's got this blah,
blah.
What about the Diet?
But it's part of the whole thing,
right?
It's like he's a glutton.
Would girls complain if you look like
Brad Pitt though?
Tony Hinchcliffe
has a bit.
Oh,
it doesn't want to.
I want to tell you that bit.
I wasn't trying to screw us on these
bit.
He doesn't use that as an example,
but it's a great bit.
You have to see it.
I don't want to even paraphrase you give
it away.
No,
no,
you didn't.
It's a great bit.
It actually involves a Louis C.
K it's a great,
I love it.
It's really fucking funny.
Tony's brilliant.
I don't want to tell you where it goes
because it goes even crazier off and
I'll see it.
Are you gonna see him tonight?
Uh,
yeah.
He's at the store.
I'm at the store to him.
I heard or I took them on the road with
me this past week.
He's killing her and murder and he
murdered them in Nashville.
Murdered,
murdered him in Charlotte.
A lot of,
a lot of rednecks.
Ackland Woo.
Really?
Tony had to go to war because gluck
heckling Tony.
I mean,
he's a writer for the roast for guts.
He's so witty.
I fucked up one time.
It had let my shield down.
It's telling him I almost started crying
and comedy central and I just feel as
neck gets stiff,
he goes and right away I'm like,
oh,
Harry coms.
And then he was like,
you almost cried and comedy central and
then just roasted me for basically the
rest of the shell.
Why would you,
why did you almost crying comedy
central?
Just cause it's full circle for Gallic
Miyubi on county central doing stand up.
You know,
it was just a special night for me and
I,
and during this,
the story that I tell,
I talked about how I realize that's
never become UFC champ.
But being on comedy central and a Judd
apatow towns,
when the books I've read,
when a super,
you know,
concern and comedy and that day at
[inaudible],
my show that night did comedy central,
I don't know,
it just hit me in that moment was on
stage at a strip club where they shoot
it and I don't know,
I got emotional.
I was like,
do you need to get your shit together
man?
You gotta get your shit together,
you're happy.
I was happy.
I as emotional man.
And then it said that on the pockets,
feel close,
Nico,
Nico.
And I was like,
Oh fuck.
He's like,
this isn't comedy central in 2010 and
just went nuts man.
Well,
Hey Ange,
because I've always had a thing with
comedy central.
Yeah.
For whatever's gonna burn his side about
them.
Like they didn't appreciate him.
He's a very underrated guy man.
Like right now he's still to this day,
he's right now he's underrated.
I agree.
And I think with your show and we were,
he was closed I think.
Got,
yeah,
I mean he's a monster in our show.
The most underrated guy who I,
who should be sent out theaters just
feel Vaughn,
well we were talking about that before
too.
Has got,
he hit a stride,
like within the last year he had a
stride where he just like,
sometimes you'll see dudes,
they,
they're doing really well and then for
whatever reason they figure something
out and they take it to the next
breakthrough.
And that's worth Theo is right now he's
just,
he's,
and he's a unique guy.
Like his comedy is so unique.
Like it wouldn't work with anybody.
You don't see it anywhere else.
It's us telling me sometimes I'll watch
other comedians and I'll go,
I can see how they came up with that
idea.
And I watched the,
I'm like,
what the fuck?
What the fuck you smoking?
Yeah.
Where are you coming up?
Where were you raised?
How old?
How's that race?
By a fucking pack of crocodiles in New
Orleans.
Did you come up with this?
Yeah,
he's,
but even just hanging around with him
like offstage.
He's just a weird dude.
Oh Bro.
He pulled up at the store yesterday and
you just got a new car.
I don't,
I won't say the car.
Nice car.
We'd like it.
And uh,
he,
I go,
dude,
you're killing it man.
That your car is.
Yeah.
And he has some homosexual.
Bumped into the back.
Can Be there.
Why is he a homosexual?
He's like,
cause he was,
I'm like,
all right.
It just happened.
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
He's like just having a big,
he's just so hilarious,
man.
Yeah,
there's a lot of good guys right now.
I was talking about,
uh,
watching that garry shandling stuff and
doing all the stuff.
Judd's document's Jet Aptos documentary.
It's brilliant.
On his process and stuff like that.
I got emotional on that as well.
I don't know if guys know this,
obviously I'm a complete bitch.
Uh,
but guess Shannon talks about how his
goal through going through everything
was to get on the tonight show and then
he does it and he walks backstage and
kills it.
Right?
But that was his goal and he starts
crying.
He falls in a Bob Sag,
it's arms starts crying.
Right?
Cause that was his goal.
But he's talking about the comedy store
and like he's talking about all the big
names there.
And I was thinking,
God,
that must've been cool to be involved in
that back then around all this big
names.
I was talking to Brian,
Brian Goes,
man,
right now the comedy store,
some would argue it's better and we
think about it.
I'm like,
God,
it is.
When you think about all the fucking
just legends,
man,
you [inaudible] you got married and got
delete.
I mean just the list goes on and on and
on.
I'm like,
oh my God,
it's bad man.
It's a crazy time.
It's certainly the best time at the
store in terms of like the amount of
time that I've been there and I started
going there in [inaudible] 94.
It's a long time.
It's a long ass time.
So in 24 years that I've been going
there,
it's better now than ever before.
But when you think about it,
I mean obviously there's the seller in
New York,
but as far as like on a give,
you go there on a Tuesday night and
Wednesday night,
I mean it's fricking,
yeah,
they're very similar.
They're very similar in a way.
Um,
but,
and they're also very similar in that
they become big tourist traps to like
comedy store.
People take vacations for comedy,
they do comedy vacations and they fly
from Australia,
getting a lot of people from Australia.
But because you know,
if you show up,
uh,
you're going to see bill burr,
Rogan,
Mark Baron and delete in the same night
almost every week.
One of us is there sounds at least,
unless someone's on tour,
so it's off.
Yeah.
I in a lot of times you are on tour.
Um,
but shit on any given Tuesday,
Dave Chappelle might stop it.
Correct.
And then Chris Rock's rock,
maybe Louis don't make us come back
there.
I hope he does.
I'm going to lose people like come on,
come on.
You like people watching you beat off.
I mean this is worth shit.
Come on.
Yeah.
Just need someone to come up.
Someone has to do some much more
horrible,
you know,
calen shooting his special I think in
July.
No,
he is through uh,
some,
I forget who's who's shooting it,
but definitely not as buddy works for
espn this time.
So they're doing it right there.
He's doing it right time.
But I,
they're gonna go out there and try and
sell it,
but he's ready to go.
I just hope it works out for count as
far as Netflix or showtime or somewhere
you got to land somewhere,
you know.
Is he going to sell it and then bring it
somewhere?
Is that the move?
I think so.
I don't want to misquote Brian,
but I'm,
I'm most positive,
but he has someone who I think he shot
[inaudible] girls and a bunch of other
guys stuff like it's someone who knows
what the hell they're doing.
Where's he going to do it?
Uh,
I think Chicago.
Ooh,
Chicago in July.
Yeah.
That's a good spot.
I'm there for the UFC in June.
I'm doing the Chicago theater.
June 7th or some shit.
I love Chicago.
Whew.
That sounds,
I did Chicago theater.
Chicago.
Yeah.
It's great.
It's beautiful.
Beautiful place to,
yeah.
Chicago's awesome man.
Doesn't get enough love to weird place,
right?
It does it not get enough love.
I feel like everyone fucking loves
Chicago.
Their pizza people won't shut up about
not really pizza.
It's casserole.
It's a casserole.
Correct.
Yeah.
It's like a wrap calling that a peanut.
That's not a pizza.
If you took large,
thick square,
that would be a casserole.
And I come from,
have you ever hamburger and you roll it
up in a Tortilla?
Is that still a hamburger?
No.
That's the Tortilla.
And I rap.
That's a Burrito.
But just proteins.
That's lettuce.
We call that out.
Let us Taco.
That's a lettuce wrap.
Chinese food place,
chicken,
Sasha wrapped.
See the differences the way you make it.
It's rolled up.
Look,
you could take a piece of pizza and
flatten it out and fold it over,
over and over again,
and then it'll become folded pizza.
But if it starts out folded,
what are you selling me?
It's a cal zone.
Yeah,
he me a Goddamn cal zone.
I love the cows.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of cows on how to get thick
piece of pizza from a basic casserole
from Chicago though.
Yeah.
Oh yes.
You've ever had though.
Very good.
The best you've ever had.
What did,
where's the place we go to?
So what is it called you or Donna is
that one might've been,
you know who makes a nice square piece?
Is King's in New York or have you ever
heard of a Ah,
fuck it.
I'm getting it.
The artichoke pizza in New York.
Artichoke P it's called artichoke pizza
of Dev ripped pants to get in there.
No Sir.
People kept telling me go there.
When I was in New York working with
showtime,
I tried one slice,
you know postmates,
postmates what makes me fat now?
Because I made posts,
get food,
drops it off to your hotel room.
So I get done after a long day of pr,
I'm like,
pizza be great.
So I get two slices.
I'm like,
next night.
fuck,
that was delicious.
I see.
No,
my gut,
I fucking love handles and a kitchen.
Isn't it weird how like when you tired,
you want carbs,
wants sugar and carbs.
I wonder why.
I think it's like my willpower is weak.
Yeah.
Like I want like I never fuck with egg
mcmuffins or mcgriddles my mouse water.
But if I'm at the airport and I'm on a
fucking 7:00
AM flight,
you and I working together.
I never eat that shit.
You and I it together so good for the
brief moment it was in my mouth,
dude.
You know what I was thinking?
I'm like,
God love him.
Be Grill,
but I don't wanna be judged right now.
I'm going to wait to see if he goes to
that fucking weird place on the
breakfast spot on the right or is he
getting going to Mcdonald's and we
started leaning over there.
I went and I want to be,
I wouldn't be mad at egg mcmuffin.
And you've looked at,
yeah,
fuck this.
Let's do this.
Yes.
I ate before I saw you guys.
I thought you would skip it.
You want to be the guy who pulls the
trigger.
You don't wanna be judged,
man.
Yeah,
most of the time I'm going to not pull
the trigger,
but it's,
I feel like that's part of the thing.
It's like pulling that trigger every now
and then for the fuck of it.
I have some fun.
Get chicken and waffles.
Go to Roscoe's,
go to Roscoe's in slatter.
That motherfucker with maple syrup and
butter.
You just can't do it every day.
You can't do it every day,
but you do it one day a week.
I agree.
Rock his,
his instagram,
like those pictures of him meeting
stacks and stacks of pancakes.
Definitely a photo shoot.
Yeah,
I hear you.
You Ain't you and all that.
So you think so?
No,
that's definitely so a giant.
You don't think he eats all that shit?
Yeah,
he's not a judge.
I mean he,
he,
he's on different supplements than I am.
We're both very similar size,
different supplements,
supplements,
Supplement pays and they come from south
of the border.
I'm sure he's eating the same
[inaudible] you ain't the same tacos and
you see he came out and he has
depression.
I think he's,
it's football thing,
man.
I think.
Um,
and then also pro wrestling,
all that slamming.
I like getting slammed around.
This is my take on this,
I think.
I mean you,
I'm sure you've dealt with depression,
right?
Do you have bummer days,
Jamie?
Haft bummer days,
right?
Shit happens.
I think there's a difference between
having a depression period in your life
or event in your life.
And then,
you know,
you're normally a happy dude and there's
people with severe depression who has to
be medicated.
There's this scale.
Yeah.
And he's not on that scale.
Now he's on that scale.
Makes News.
Cause he goes,
Hey,
I've been sad to before.
Like,
yes.
Rocket Sat.
Two different sad.
We're not talking about you should fear
depressed here.
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
He was talking about his mom was Ari
Shaffir depressed out.
Mike Royko.
His mom walked into traffic and I'm,
and I'm not throwing shade at Ari.
We've talked about already having
depression before and he takes
medication.
That's why I said that he doesn't
anymore.
He's off medication and he's Hilarious
magically.
Oh,
weird.
Yeah.
He's a phenomenal comic and successful
and he's not depressed.
Also,
he got off propecia callen calls pull
shan.
I counseled taking propecia like their
skittles and he's the happiest man I
know.
Yeah.
But it's not necessarily like universal.
Like some people can take penicillin and
they don't have a problem.
Other people are allergic to it.
Yeah.
But I think it's a rare case where he'd
take propecia and get depressed.
Oh.
Think is are rare.
I bet if you look at the studies and
this come from countless,
I mean this is bro Science.
Calvin just wants that hair,
wants to keep that hair so bad.
I'll do anything.
You know what?
I think you should go.
Well.
Good fat one red one.
Yes.
Just go crazy so I can yank it off and I
want to wear a wig so bad like one of
those,
those mesh net ones,
just like the Lebron sprayed
on look almost looks like a Pittsburgh
steeler helmet.
Ron Still doing that?
Yeah,
kind of.
definitely.
You just got to let it go.
Question on this though.
Wouldn't you take from Kesha because
you're a little depressed because your
hair's falling out and if it didn't
work,
you're going to stay correct.
A little depressed.
So fucks with your Dick game.
Yeah,
maybe.
But I think what they're saying is like
suicidal depression that there's
something about the dht inhibitor
dihydrotestosterone which is derivative
of testosterone is what causes you to
have your hair fall out.
The dht inhibiting factors in propecia
with some people it adds to it.
It's a low percentage.
So I'm pretty sure might be
the study this comes from,
which I just,
I would google,
it might've been more than one study was
in 2012 and it was only 61 men.
Oh the only did 61 minute.
How many got depressed,
said a 61 man who formerly use propecia,
who experienced more than three months
of sexual side effects and had no
history of depression,
sexual problems of any sort.
Yeah.
I don't know,
Dude.
If I'm losing my hair and my Dick won't
get up and I'd be depressed too.
Yeah.
Do stock take.
And then also you've got to figure out
like what's happening in your love life.
If you're depressed and your Dick
doesn't work.
Correct.
But also up philosophy,
if you had a nine to five job you hate
and that pay the bills and then you got
family drama,
11% of those,
I guess 11% of the 61 which would be
what?
Six of them,
five or six had mild symptoms,
symptoms of depression.
28 had moderate and 36 had severe.
Whoa.
36 had severe.
Uh,
I mean,
so that's also then when you're asking
them,
so it's like,
what is the step?
What was the study on a second?
Did you say 61 people?
36% percent had severe depression.
I found that 44% of the men had
experienced thoughts of suicide.
Hold on.
I'm already hold on Jesus Christ to 4%
right.
But that's what I'm also going in.
Like what were they,
would they just ask them like,
have you ever thought of it because
you're like,
well,
did they call it the scientific study?
I'm sure there's some sort of protocol
they have to follow.
Let me understand this though.
66 people were randomly out of how many
people took it,
right?
It says
the Journal of Clinical Psych,
psychiatric psychiatry,
I'm sorry,
study included 61 men.
That's what it,
so what does that like 28 dudes wanted
to kill themselves.
That's fucking crazy.
That property show.
Fuck that.
I just don't ball jude.
Ari said it like it was like almost
instant and he never put the two of them
together.
Never put the dough in depression with
the,
with the suicidal thoughts like it,
all of it came like white when he got
out.
I'm like,
you know,
he had had some issues in the past with
being depressed after breakups.
Normal Shit.
Like everybody has it.
But it wasn't,
that's not the case.
I know want to kill me.
He didn't know.
He didn't,
Ari's kind of a stoic dude.
He's very proud and he doesn't talk a
lot about stuff.
And so it took like me and him hanging
where he like wasn't talking and I was
like,
okay,
what's a matter?
And he's like,
dude,
it's just hard.
It's hard to just not kill myself.
He said that to you?
And I went blind.
Yeah.
So we were playing pool at my house and
I was like,
what?
I go,
what's going on?
So he starts telling me,
um,
they put him on medication and the
medication didn't work and then they put
him on another medication and then that
didn't work.
And you know,
he's with Sag,
it's Sag Aftra insurance,
not the best insurance.
And he's like,
I don't know what to do.
Um,
and I'm like,
okay,
this is one of my best friends.
And he's reaching out.
I'm like,
Hey,
saints,
up for a reason.
And I don't have any experience with
that.
I mean,
I've had some bomber moments in my life,
but I would never say that I was
depressed.
I'm,
I'm pretty,
pretty happy birthday and depressed
though.
Yes.
If that bad moments,
but I'm not,
I'm not,
I've never gone through depression.
I've never been down for like six
months.
Couldn't get out of bed or thought about
suicide.
No,
this is a scale of that shit.
He was,
he was on,
uh,
the dark end of this game.
That's what he was thinking about
killing himself and trying to,
trying to not do it.
So,
um,
I just started making some phone calls
and I found,
um,
my business manager found the best
psychiatrist,
like you said,
like this guy is a wizard.
He's dealt with a bunch of my clients
before.
He's,
he's helped out a lot.
It was very expensive.
So I just paid for it not to say yes to
life.
I just told Paul No,
I mean,
I'm thinking about it that way.
for Ari,
he couldn't afford it at all.
So I always like,
yeah,
I'm sure a great option.
I can't afford this.
Yeah.
You know,
he was getting by,
I'm winning poker tournament and getting
the occasional commercial goes this
quite a few years ago.
I want to say like 2000,
I dunno,
it was quite a few years ago,
2004 some shit like that.
I Dunno,
I don't remember when it was.
Sure.
But it was far enough back where
[inaudible] was really struggling as a
comedian.
I mean he's,
I used talked about this publicly or
otherwise I wouldn't talk.
No,
that's why,
that's why I brought it up that he's
talked about it publicly.
I'm not Erin,
he's lane dirty laundry out then I love
art.
I mean,
I don't know what caused it.
If it was that I can't stop coughing
today.
Like my,
my kids are sick as fuck my youngest one
and everyone gets it.
Yeah.
Um,
he just,
his career wasn't going well cause he
was,
you know,
it was just getting the ballroom really.
But I really think it was the pro show.
He don't you think he was the perfect
storm propecia career?
Who knows what's going on with his girl
and then it's just this fucking perfect
storm.
The propecia is making you even more
depressed.
They're like,
dude,
I'll think about killing myself.
What the fuck is going on right now?
But anyway,
darts.
So he pulled out of it,
got off the prepuce show,
um,
and then his career took the fuck off.
Right.
He got on good medication,
whatever the medication,
his new psychiatrist got him on,
worked like a charm and like he was
better in like couple months,
a couple months.
He was like back to Ari fucking around
laughing.
Then oddly enough,
when it started working really well for
him,
then his career started taking off.
Right.
Of course.
That's how it works.
I'm a standup,
started taking off his career,
started taking off,
he became happier,
got off the propecia and then weaned
himself off the drugs and now he's good.
Now he's good.
Yeah.
That was great to see.
But he smokes a lot of weed and I always
wonder like,
is that how much of that is self
medicating?
Yep.
But it's okay.
But you smoke a ton of weed.
It's not a self medicating though,
right?
No,
I like it.
I just liked doing it.
Then you're not a doctor.
It makes you,
it makes you vulnerable.
It makes you think about shit.
It makes you nervous.
Like she like makes you pause and you
don't just take things for granted when
you get high,
you start thinking about,
my problem is I smoked the other night.
I couldn't sleep in US thinking about a
lot of things.
And then I got this thought in my head
cause it's some weird shit man.
Let's talk to him.
Uh,
uh,
thing.
I was telling calendars that hate when
my,
when I think like this,
but I was in San Jose and I saw this mom
with two homeless kids and that,
and um,
I was at the store and I was going to
buy an expensive sweater and I felt so
guilty.
So when he got cash and gave this mom
bunch of cash and uh,
she started crying and I'm like,
fuck man.
And there's like this weird die around
the kids.
And the kid was about my son's age,
about two sitting there,
this little girl.
And I thought,
I thought,
I dunno why I had this random thought
once he grabbed her by the lake and
spiked on the ground.
I don't know why.
I know,
I know.
And then I didn't,
and I gave her the cash felt better
because more people around like no one's
gonna let that happen to a kid.
And so that whole night fucked up at it
and its own reach out to him.
Like,
dude,
that's her side hustle.
She does that all the time.
She's actually not,
we've seen her like raise those kids on
the street.
She gets picked up by a husband.
It's a shitty deal.
So I'm like,
all right,
that's fine.
Then I smoked weed,
right.
And I'm,
I'm laying in bed and then I had this
visual,
so don't do that to my son.
I go to sleep.
I felt sick to my stomach.
I know,
it's weird.
Like sometimes we'd,
I can think if I think about a bid,
I think that some are good on this cool
road.
But then if that creeps in there and
then it's like it kept coming up.
It was so visual and I was like sick to
my stomach.
I mean it's,
my son woke up at five and I fucking
beeline to his room and just like
squeeze the fuck em for the rest of the
morning.
It's hard,
man.
Nobody knows how much you love a person,
how much you can love a person until you
have a kid.
Correct.
Once you one says that,
everyone says that and I'm like,
okay,
okay everyone.
I know you told me that Brian till
everyone told me this,
but then once you have a kid it's like,
I don't know man.
It's just a different animal where now
like I,
when I see the shootings,
when I see,
you know the,
the,
the nuclear war talk with North Korea
and Russia,
I think God and I see that a lot of
negativity on social media,
stuff like that.
I'm like,
the world is such a kind of a fucked up
place if you want to look into that
stuff and when to have a kid.
I think about him like,
God,
man,
what's it going to be like when he's
like 16 or 18 like what kind of world is
going to be when he's 18 of I think too
hard about it.
That's when I'll get depressed.
Well,
I think the world's going to be okay.
I mean for sure.
I don't mean to bring this part just
down Obama.
No,
but horrible things are going to happen
no matter what.
Correct.
But you know,
it changes who you are.
When you have a kid,
it really does.
You're or you're a piece of shit or
you're sociopath and he's such.
Just if you're around the kid enough,
it changes who you are.
And if you're not around the kid,
it changes who you are because then you
realize you're not around the kid and
that that's going to take a piece out of
who you think you are.
But you know what?
If,
if you,
if you and we have friends who aren't
great dads or whatever and you could see
it in their kids.
I can I,
and I'm,
I'm not up psychologists or I'm some
expert in parenting,
but if I go to a person's house and I
see the way the kids treat the pants,
I go,
you're not around enough man.
I can,
I promise you.
I can tell my son doesn't act like that.
Yeah.
Cause one thing that you can call me
whenever you want,
whenever you want.
One thing I am is a beast of a dad.
I know that.
I don't know if I'm get comic.
I don't know if I was a good fighter.
I don't know if from good podcasts are,
that's all up for debate.
One thing I know is I'm a fucking good
dad man.
Good for you man.
That's a,
it's a very,
very,
very important quality and that quality,
when your kid becomes an adult,
that's going to be just a major factor
in how you get along.
You know,
I give you,
I mean even parents,
I know friends had had bad relationships
with their parents when they live with
them and then once they got out,
their parents were nice to them,
but the parents were shitty to them when
they were kids and they always hold it
against a whole always.
They always have that shit in the back
of their head like,
why were you a dick when I was 12 you
know that,
that,
that shit is always in their head.
It's like that Avatar horse when you're
young,
you,
you mixed together and if you don't make
together when you're young it,
yeah.
And I was talking to someone,
a therapist,
they're saying,
I think it's from like til they're
three.
If you don't make that connection.
Yeah.
When,
when you're like,
oh,
when they're for like,
I'll do it now it's almost too late
because they already developed these,
this,
these brain pathways were like,
Nope,
my dad's an ass and there's really
nothing can do to fix it.
Yeah,
man.
I went to the movies yesterday with my
kid,
my movie.
We went to see the Romeo and Juliet.
Oh yeah.
What is it?
A sherlock gnomes.
Yeah,
that's true.
Like no cute little movie.
Yeah.
But you know,
we went to that Synopsis Place,
but you know,
you lean back,
you know those things.
Yeah.
Seats,
lean back,
good food and you take the uh,
the seat rest down and she just,
my seven year old just snuggles with me
best.
They're snuggling watching a movie.
I'm like,
I couldn't be happier.
I don't want to see the stupid fucking
movie.
No,
but I don't care.
She wants to so I couldn't be happier.
I sat there and watched us.
Silly knows shit movie.
Yeah.
She just a little snuggle bunny.
I've watched her last baby nine times by
not a bad mood.
And like a week though,
that's pretty funny movie.
I'm boss.
Baby's great alcohol with the voice.
I watched like nine times,
but my son whenever watch,
he snuggled that when he,
when usually this is why I want a
daughter.
That's why I'm jealous you have
daughters because daughters loved their
dads.
My son.
I'm like,
you little traitor mommy,
mommy.
Like,
dude,
it's me every morning.
Your car
for your mom are like that too.
And a lot of ways it's just,
you got to accept the fact that the mom
is not just the soft sweet woman in the
house,
but she's also the person who made them
in the her body and there's chemicals
connect out of her body.
Man.
There's no,
like I had to deal with my wife.
Like I'm not naming any kids.
I go,
I got veto power.
but you do way more work.
Like it's way harder to make the person
I go.
As long as you try to call the kid
applesauce or something.
Fucking stupid.
Yeah.
You know,
I just don't feel like it's,
it's not even proposition.
Oh,
I did this fucker.
We're going to do anyways.
But now we all deal with this.
See,
you got a bonus.
You get a bonus overtime for you.
It is kinda crazy though,
that sex is how you make people I know
and everybody wants,
just wants to fuck all the time and you
want to fuck a bunch of people.
A lot of people don't want kids.
No.
Hell No.
You know,
who opened my eyes like in a big way,
uh,
in a podcast recently that's really been
making me think a lot about this is Bret
Weinstein.
He's the,
the professor that gotten that.
Do you know that?
You know,
he is controversy with the Evergreen
universities and all that,
and they were taking the day,
it wasn't a pronoun thing.
It was the day of absence.
They wanted all the white people to stay
home.
And he's like,
that's racist.
Yeah.
Anyway,
he was on,
you said there's two different things
that men are attracted to.
They're attracted to a woman that they
think would be a great companion and a
great mother.
And like someone who,
he said there's a difference between hot
and beautiful.
Correct.
Like some women are beautiful and like
they're loving you want to be around
them.
It goes,
but then there's other women who are
just hot and in males that very
receptive woman who doesn't require any
commitment,
was an opportunity for men to spread
their seed with someone who they didn't
have to be around for.
Wow.
Yeah.
So there's literally like a programming
in a man's mind.
So you see a girl with big giant tits
and a little waist and a fat ass hanging
out of her shorts and she's got sloppy
makeup on and she looks at you and
you're like,
oh,
okay,
let's do this.
But that's what that is.
It's not like live with her.
You let,
you're not saying,
I would like to start a relationship
with you.
It's like,
no,
I want to shoot my load into you and
then you raise my kid when I'm nowhere
near you because it's an opportunity for
my dna to propagate.
Wow.
So much sense.
It makes so much sense.
I literally never considered it until he
brought it up on the podcast.
I went,
oh Duh,
me neither.
I just thought she's hot.
She's just hot,
dirty in a dirty way.
Why she so attracted to that?
Why is she so dirty?
I told my girl,
Joe,
I told my girl Joe,
probably four weeks into it,
five weeks we were getting serious and
she got this job offer to go to Miami.
She was talking about career and stuff
like that and I went,
no,
that's all cool.
It's all I know one's career first more
than me.
However,
uh,
you know,
you're put on the search to be a mom,
right?
Like you're going to be such a beast of
a mom.
I guarantee you,
because I saw her interact with Callan's
kids.
I can guarantee you that you might be
the greatest host in the world,
but you're going to be the best mom I've
ever seen.
And then she's like,
really?
I'm like,
I guarantee you fucking Bam Bam.
Well that's just those qualities.
They can see it's something and when
someone's not,
when someone's a bad mom,
it's such a depressed man.
Nothing worse.
So depressing to be around women.
I was like really short with her kids
and Shitty with them and like,
oh well even as a kid,
if I had friends who like talked back to
the parents are mean to their parents.
Oh God,
what's wrong with you?
If I was dating a girl,
she'd like bad mouth,
their mom.
Like what's wrong with you girl?
And the hard thing is that pattern hard
to break.
It's hard to break.
Those kids may very well have that same
kind of behavior towards their kids.
Like when they become adults,
it's a hard pattern to break.
Sometimes you need the right person in
your life.
It's like a good person in your life
that you,
you know,
a wife or husband or whoever it is.
You know when you,
you match up with that person,
like it changes who you are too.
That's what I always say that one of the
most important things about um,
community,
like your community of friends.
Yeah.
It's when you have good friends,
those people change you.
Like you react.
Like everyone is your tribe.
You react like everyone's your friends,
so you want good for them.
You love them,
you care about them.
They change who you are.
They change if they inspire you or they
like it.
Whether they inspire you with being
smart or their kindness or their
ambition,
whatever it is that we're on.
We're not individuals.
We're a piece of a community always.
And that community,
even if it's a small community that you
call a family,
that piece is dependent upon who you do
that piece with.
A,
you might be an amazing dad with the
right woman,
but with the wrong woman,
you might be so frustrated with the
relationship that you're not as good at
data right now.
There might be chaos going on all the
time.
You might be situations you put the kid
in when you're yelling and screaming at
each other of the kitchen and see all
these different factors that are
dependent upon your relationship with
this other person.
And they changed you and you change
them.
Like you might be the wrong person for
They might be super cool and calm with
someone else,
but with you,
they just,
it's just not a mitch.
It doesn't hit buttons.
It's like a woman saying to you,
uh,
you know,
you don't want an equal like,
well,
I don't want this.
No,
You might be right,
but I know for sure.
I don't want that.
You're threatened.
You threatened by a strong woman.
No,
I'm threatened by you.
You're just,
you're aggressive for no reason.
Who the fuck has ever said that you
threatened by strong man to try and by
strong man.
Like it's like what?
Shut up cause he was he calling yourself
a strong man.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Any guy who calls himself a strong man
like that job most likely's up pitch.
Most likely.
It's just trying to prop himself.
And I feel the same way about women who
say that women who were like,
you know,
you're scared of a strong woman.
Like okay,
am I really or are you a cocked?
Yup.
Oh are you a call?
Just a raging cause this talk,
this sounds like this guy can't talk.
And again,
super uncomfortable.
I don't know what got us to this,
but whatever I did
please,
I'll apologize.
But I also feel like in,
in,
in this community of friends that were
talking about if you are a shit father,
it would show elsewhere in your life
around us.
Or if we're at the comedy store,
we're a restaurant or in your,
in your social media,
it's going to come out one way or
another.
You know,
tough to be in that group.
You know the expression,
how you do one thing is how you do
everything.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
I think there's something to that.
I mean obviously there's people that are
really good at one thing and then suck
at other things.
So it's not a,
it's not always a hundred percent
correct.
But you know,
if you're a shitty dad,
you're going to be a shitty friend.
I agree.
And if you're a shitty friend,
you're probably going to be shitty.
Dad and I,
and I say this too,
with like with due to our shitty debt
dads,
it's like,
right.
If you're willing to do that to your,
literally your connect to this person,
chemically,
they're,
they're made of your DNA.
If you're on a treat him like that.
When the going gets rough for me,
where the fuck are you going to be?
Right.
There's no way I want you to my foxhole.
Yeah,
that's big man.
And then people that don't,
they don't understand that.
They understand what they're doing
wrong.
That's rough too.
And the Bummer,
the people that can't see it and you try
to explain it to them and they can't see
it.
The one thing people will put up with
though,
as in I would never do this,
but if you give someone parenting
advice,
just doesn't,
there's just,
there's certain things you can't talk
about.
Usually politics,
religion and parenting.
The only way I think parenting advice
works ever is if you talk about one
great thing that you found that you do
with your kid without criticizing none
other pests,
you could,
you could give them advice but not give
them advice by like you can relay your
personal positive experiences and either
they take it or they don't.
But as soon as you start saying,
hey man,
I see how you talk to your son and
you're like,
what?
What the fuck did you say to your son is
uh,
you know,
he's an individual man.
You treat her like an object.
Like fuck,
I don't fucking treat my son like all
the time came over.
He's not even listening.
What you said you,
you're all ramping up.
My son was one and a half at the time
and I was taken to this,
this play area and he,
you know,
he did not express himself and everyone
was older and you'd hit kids and he's a
big kid.
He's a 99% tile for size and all that
stuff and he would hit kids and the the
place where I was taking him in
Brentwood knew I was a former fighter.
One of the guys who works front desk as
a fan.
I've talked mma with them and they took
me to the side and said,
you know,
we got a bit of a problem because tiger
is hitting kids and we think it's in
direct correlation of you let them watch
fights and from,
I just started laughing,
you guys are silly as fuck.
Hey,
I'm never bring them back.
B.
He's one and a half.
Everyone else in their s three I mean,
yeah,
he cold cock that kid with a left hook
and I'm proud of,
I'm proud of,
I could took his toy.
However,
it's just,
this is what kids do.
They hit man.
It's nothing that we,
and I tell him,
no,
I'm staying on top of my helicopter.
The parent the fuck out of him when he's
in there,
but these,
these one and a half there were,
are older and have,
trust me,
he's not watching UFC.
It's not has nothing to do the side.
This lady was like that.
You have F C or whatever you're getting
into.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is some Brentwood shit lady.
There's a lot of shit right now.
All right,
yellow,
meet dirt.
If they hit each other,
they hate each other.
We're concerned that you are constantly
reaffirming his gender without him
choosing were concerned.
Some,
I was reading something about some lady
on a three year old trans kid.
I'm like,
oh my God,
how about are you sure?
Are you positive and not just a kid.
You're three.
Oh,
you mean the how?
He's into cars this week.
Next week.
I mean trolls.
They want to chop his dick off while
they were like,
this article was like really super
positive about it.
Ah,
bringing the kid to therapy and shit and
aiding his transition.
My keys fucking three in this.
I just read this like two days ago.
I was like,
this is so nuts.
There's so much that it's going on right
now and I want to be a transformed when
us three you don't see my dad,
Pun fucking mechanical arms on me.
Imagine if I was three arms on me.
I'm 19 like what the Fuck Dad?
Why am I a robot now?
Well,
when you were three told you want to be
a robot,
it's the same shit is the same shit.
It's crazy.
It's insane.
It's so weird.
It's so weird that people are just
openly jumping into this and it's these
weirdo super,
you know,
ideological progressive people that
just,
they're locked into this idea that it's
amazing to have a trans kid and the kid
shows any sign whatsoever of being
inclining to be female or inclined to be
mailed.
They're pushing it.
I'm like,
Oh God,
I feel like it's actually bad.
Well,
it's also very dangerous because they
start wanting to fuck with the kids
hormones.
Like you got to let the child develop.
There's no real science and what the
fuck happens when you put hormone
blockers new,
a three year old and try to transition
them into a girl,
but also the real doctors,
you know what the hell they're doing.
They're not going to inject that kid
with hormones.
So you can say,
listen,
if you want to do this when you're 1819
even then it's a little too early,
but when you're 21 which is again,
it's too early.
The,
and I've seen this on some of the
bullshit reality TV shows that much,
but these legit doctoral,
then I'm willing to help you out.
But before then get out of here.
No,
get out.
Let's see where yet.
When you're 16th there's a market for
it,
which is a cruel thing to say in a weird
way to describe it.
Here's the problem,
John.
We were talking about,
you know,
on the spectrum,
for some of those kids,
they do feel like they're trapped in a
woman's body.
You know what,
and I feel for them that must suck to go
through high school and all that.
But isn't that the exception?
You know what I'm saying?
Like is that kit the exception that
feels like,
and they should have access to it.
How could you do that with a three year
old?
I know.
I mean,
how do you know?
you just don't and anybody says he do.
Your crazy people change.
You change when hormones get entered
into your body and maybe you won't be
the most masculine man in the world and
maybe you will turn into a woman someday
maybe,
but give yourself a goddamn chance to
just exist.
Do you see the high school wrestler?
Yes.
The girl just beaten up.
Right.
And that had been then she waves at test
booze like a motherfucker.
I know it's not fair.
She should be able to out to russel boy
or he should be allowed to wrestle boys,
you know,
but you know,
whatever man.
It's crazy.
You're,
you're taking a high school girl and
you're filling her up with testosterone,
with injections.
What?
It's nuts.
And then you're allowing you to wrestle
girls that aren't on testosterone.
It's fucking cheating.
Okay.
If she was just a girl and she wasn't
like trying to transition into a man and
they found out that she was winning the
state championship as a woman or as a
girl,
rather by taking steroids,
they would take it away from it.
She would say she's cheating.
They'd be,
there'd be an uproar.
Do not let her wrestle.
Yes.
Not let her wrestling with the law.
Why?
Because if they go,
we can't wrestle with the boys and I'll
just can't rest that all the rest of the
boys more don't wrestle.
I would say she,
that's what she wants.
What's the rest of the boys?
She,
they,
they're these zero reserves.
Um,
yeah,
I,
I think it,
hey,
if you,
if you're going to choose to go that
path of this transitioning to a female,
then you give up your right to wrestle
because we don't have a division for
that vet and get and we don't have
enough wrestling.
She's transitioning to he and it's just,
it's not fair.
It was,
if it was the other way,
it would be more fair because like if
you're a man and you're transitioning to
be a woman and they make you wrestle men
while you're going to be at a
disadvantage because you are taking
hormone blockers or you're getting
castrated,
you're losing your test to goals,
your whatever,
whatever it is,
you are at a disadvantage.
You that aspect.
Yeah.
He's at a disadvantage now transitioning
to,
I mean he's added a massive advantage
right now,
transitioning to a man there.
He's on steroids.
You're got up the kids on steroids on
100% and probably a lot of them probably
a lot of it because they're trying to
turn him into a man.
Correct.
It's all nuts,
but I know like where was this 30 years
ago?
It was it just like a silent epidemic.
There's everyone just under cover.
It was like,
God,
I feel like a woman.
You know.
There was a few of those.
There was like that one guy,
Renee Richards,
that the tennis player that wound up
transitioning.
He was a terrible male tennis player,
transitioned to a female tennis player
and start dominating Joanna man.
That's the plot of Joanna man tennis
addition.
Now that movie,
No,
it was do you want him?
I want a man was the guy who couldn't,
he get suspended from like the Lakers,
the fake Lakers in the movie.
So he's like,
God,
I want to play basketball.
So like you could make the women's team.
He just wore a wig and put tvs on us.
Started dunking on bitches.
Well,
that does happen today.
There was a guy who was ready for this
50 years old.
He was six foot four or five,
played women's college basketball
because he played as a man,
but now he's not a man anymore.
Now this fool is a fucking war.
He's a fool.
If you went past and you're 50 years old
and you're pretending to be a college
girl and be like,
I'm in a fantasy where out my fantasy
and she's a giant and she's swatting
basketballs out of people's hands.
There's Joanna man.
Yeah.
See if you could find the guy who played
it was 50 type in 50 year old
transsexual man,
transsexual plays,
women's college bath in America.
Yeah.
In America.
Well,
here's the thing.
Imagine if your kid is on a team with
that person and that person takes your
kids scholarship,
takes your kids.
Look at that right there.
Fit your old aw,
seriously.
Gi Yak jacked and got 50 year old knows
on him and became a college basketball
player at fucking Mike.
Get the fuck out of here.
52 excuse me.
Gabriel Ludwig.
52.
Okay.
Two years old than me goes to college
and she ball.
Uh,
I think she played as a man.
Look at that size difference.
Now imagine your kid is competing
against her and it can't get a shot off.
Can't get a Shaquille o'neal and it's
just bullshit.
It's like if Shaquille o'neal was
playing on that other team,
if Shaquille o'neal transition to be a
woman decided to go back to college,
this college would let her play as a
woman.
That's Shaquille o'neal.
I was a woman.
What colleges?
That douche bag university.
I Dunno.
I don't want to,
I don't want to give him any press.
Press makes me sick.
I mean that's a giant man with tits.
It's straight nonsense.
This is where she get ballplayers as
the,
this is where progressiveness goes down
the rabbit hole.
What does it mission college.
That's probably a juco.
Huh?
I don't know what it is but it gets,
it could suck it.
It can suck a nonexisting.
Interesting thing.
She played college basketball for 30
years ago as a man.
I said how does she still have
eligibility?
Cause she's a woman now.
That's what I said.
Transition.
They let her,
they let her transition and when you're
transitioning you go back.
Now you're a woman.
You don't have a history of playing as a
woman,
so now you're allowed to play again for
five more years of college too.
I feel like a lot more.
Can I ask you got to do this?
There's a few that would do it.
Oh hundred percent.
Oh Dana White was joking around about
that.
Like I know a few guys that could be a
world champion.
They'd cut their dick off.
There's a few guys,
there are some guys who by all means
this there,
it's crazy to even suggest,
but so is walking into youtube shooting
a bunch of people and then shooting
yourself in the chest.
That's crazy suggest too,
that people fucking mind.
That bitch was definitely out of her
mind.
And also if you saw youtube videos,
no one or you made no fucking money,
Lee,
those videos were terrible.
Well there's something wrong with that
ladies brain.
How about her dad goes,
uh,
warned the police.
I can get any to check her out.
She didn't do something bad to youtube.
There's some,
some issues here,
but if you're a cop and they did find
her the night before at 2:00
AM cause she went missing,
they found her and they're like,
yeah,
she doesn't seem like she's gonna hurt
herself or anyone else.
I don't know what you want us to do.
Like we found her,
she's sick,
she's good.
She's sleeping in her car until someone
does something.
It's so hard to do anything about it.
Like they,
they um,
they sent that one college kid,
they're sending him back.
They found,
uh,
his roommates.
I was,
we were talking about it yesterday.
His roommates were talking about and
there were seriously worried about him.
He had a bleached his hair blonde,
started stockpiling ammunition,
bought an assault,
gone and then the cops came to visit
them and after the cops left,
he went out and bought another ar and
they're like,
okay,
okay.
That's it.
We got it.
We gotta do something about this.
His roommates are freaking out.
Like people are freaking out being
around the guy.
And they sent him back on a technicality
because he wasn't going to school cause
he stopped going to class.
It's what can you do a student visa?
What they do?
They deported him.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh perfect.
And they said,
we think we prevented the tragedy.
I love that.
Yeah,
that's exactly what they should do.
However,
would this lady,
let's say they stopped at two in the
morning,
she's in a car and the Dad,
the dad who you know,
she came from,
his seat goes,
listen,
she,
she's gonna do something bad.
We think we've seen signs,
we've known her since she was a day old.
You guys should do something about it.
I don't think you should go out.
We talked to her,
it seems all right.
Maybe take her in for the night too
though.
Talk to the therapist.
But if she doesn't do anything and then
she does like you people are so
unpredictable and get those eyebrows in
class or in jail for that video of her
doing those squats and the jumps,
that workout video,
hairball of those eyes crazy that she's
not there.
She was a different plant horror movie
and then,
but then,
and then she's mad.
She's not getting fricking revenue from
the Youtube and youtube like ah,
your videos suck lady.
We have nothing to do.
You're crazy.
You didn't come up in the open mic
circuit so you don't have a phd in
Psychos.
Like he,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
all these dudes that have been in the
grind like I remember a long time ago,
but they're fucking crazy people.
There's a certain amount of open micros
who think that they're really funny and
they can't get work and they're angry
about it and they're really fucking
crazy and killed Tony when I've been in
like two or three times.
Perfect example.
Kill Tony is a primary example.
You go there and you're like,
what in the fuck am I watching?
And if someone tries to tell that person
like maybe you should connect more with
the crop.
I connect the neck,
don't get mad.
This is my best bit.
These pitcher,
good bits.
And the people were like,
what?
And the Tony told one guy like,
dude,
you're bombing.
It was,
they were laughing.
They're laughing.
They laugh at you until he goes,
they're laughing cause you're fucking
terrible and we're making faces behind.
He goes,
that's laughing.
You don't know what the fuck you're
talking about.
Tony was like,
get off the stage.
He's like,
make me,
it's like,
oh my God,
boy.
Yeah,
but you see,
you see that too on American idol.
There'll be some crazy dude like my mom
thinks I'm the best,
you know the best things.
Lionel Richie and they get up and it
just completely bomb and then they talk
shit to the experts.
You guys just don't know what you want.
Well you have to look at people as a
whole.
Right now if you look at people as a
whole like physically,
right?
There's people that are built like you
and there's people that have built like
vern troyer.
That's just a fact.
It's just,
it's tough.
It's tough.
It's does.
It's also brilliant mind.
But my point is it's come on seven.
It's a roll of the dice.
That's the same thing with everything.
It's the same thing with your mind as
well.
It just is.
The mine varies widely.
It varies racially.
It varies interracially it varies age
wise.
Like you can have a 50 year old black
guy that's a smart guy you ever met in
your life and you're going to have a 50
year old white guy who is a fucking
moron and you're going to have a 50 year
old woman who was out of her fucking
mind and you're going to have a 50 year
old woman who's a brilliant,
you know,
physicist and you're going to have
everything you have,
every combination,
every combination of smart and stupid
and,
and the tall and thin people vary.
But they also vary with how crazy they
are.
But also that's a variable.
I think some people are crazy and then
they find a passion.
They run with it.
Maybe it's music comedy,
but then some of those crazy people who
are different than the others in high
school get made fun of,
get bullied and then that craziness
turns into darkness.
And then they get ahold of Ak 47 then
that's when you get the mass shootings.
Oh yeah.
Cause there's experiences with those
crazy people and maybe they turned the
right direction and they do something
great.
Write great songs,
come up with a great bid or come up with
a great tv show or that person gets
bullied so bad the direction they go.
It's dark,
it's fun.
Hundred percent crazy mind does crazy
stuff.
Yeah,
so 100% physical abuse,
sexual abuse along with that
medications.
Sure medications could do it and every
single mass shooters on medications.
But when you look at the combination of
all the different factors,
it's like when you see that lady crying
in her car at two o'clock in the
morning,
you're a cop.
You don't know what to do.
What do you,
what do you think you think she's going
to like?
I knew when I looked at her that she was
going to go on to youtube and shoot that
place up.
Now there's no way.
There's no way.
Nope.
But how close cruise kids,
same thing.
They came to see him two years before
they decided he wasn't a threat and the
people like the FBI's and competent know
24 months later.
First of all,
he probably got fucking crazier,
crazy,
right in 24 months.
His mom wound up dying like six months
before that,
so that probably fucked him up too.
There's probably a whole host of
factors,
but events.
Right.
But he never did it before.
How the fuck can you predict these
random shooters?
I don't know what you're going to do.
The only thing with the Youtube thing is
if the dad goes,
listen,
my daughter's can do something crazy and
they find her near the Youtube,
uh,
northern California offices.
We should at least take her in for the
night.
Talk to her,
and that's the leash.
You're not going to lose anything.
Taxpayers be happy to pay for a night in
there.
You know,
it's all,
it's all good.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know if that would do it though.
You know?
It's like that lady just seemed fucking
nuts,
man.
Someone saw and said,
uh,
someone posted it and said,
be ready to never sleep again.
That'd be didn't.
It's given me that much faith.
He,
I went,
oh,
she's bat shit crazy.
Yeah.
Like super duper batshit crazy.
Youtube was out for because they,
she was,
her views were lowering one video
though.
She had 45 views.
It's like,
come on man.
It's fucking bananas,
man.
I'm sure they pull her youtube page by
now.
Jamie.
Yeah.
And how if you're going to go out,
you right.
Most people do it to the head.
She shot herself
in the chest.
That's dot savage.
That's dark.
That's a dark way to go.
Other people have done that.
I guess people that knew they were brain
was going to get,
say I did that.
Shot himself in the chest because he
goes,
I want you to stay in my brain because
it's not good.
Fuck.
Yeah.
I can't feel good.
No,
I feel like the brain people.
Yeah.
We went dark.
We can we talk.
We got to bring it back.
We've gotten dark this pocket to bring
it back.
Let's bring it home.
Let's bring him home in a positive
thing.
But you don't stop roles.
That's a fight.
No,
it's talking about you on a rose.
Hey,
Jamie.
Tele homeboys got to watch the Monitor.
All right.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Talk rose talking about it's being
overshadowed.
Yeah,
it has been overshadowed.
It's a crazy one,
right?
It's because nobody expected it to go
down the way it did in the first one,
you know,
not at all.
And the rematch you on is on weight.
She's way lighter.
She was one 22 last week,
you know,
so she's just a few pounds away.
Here's my problem with this fight.
And I hit,
I might,
I might stop making pigs that said on a
podcast yesterday.
It doesn't make me feel good when I pick
against people.
It doesn't make me feel good.
I feel like I have to do it.
A lot of people don't do pigs and they
come to me for pigs.
What do you think's gonna Happen?
Uh,
for a long time I thought,
oof.
Rose Rose,
she's a monster.
And I know rose right from Denver.
She landed that left Hook and trevor
teaches that.
And Pat Barry teaches that and that's
exactly what to do.
Amazing fight.
I bet they fight,
you know,
three or four times.
But if they do a rematch,
which they should give you on the
immediate rematch,
rose me a little bit of trouble cause
you ana is a fucking machine.
Here's the caveat to that.
When I see you on a do interviews and
she goes,
it was my nutritionist.
It was this person,
it was this,
it was this.
She never once has she owned it and
taking credibility.
I will.
That's not the way a world champion
speaks.
That's not the way it all.
Someone talks and when I see a bunch of
excuse,
they go,
Oh shit,
you have a hole in your boat and your
cut.
You're masking it with duct tape and
you're trying to get back to this point.
You're just math.
You're not solving that.
Actually patching that up and so you're
susceptible again and now you,
you're talking like that never happened.
It was a fluke.
Yeah.
Rose is pretty fucking good and if you
don't respect her again,
you think it's your nutritionist is why
he left that fight.
You're probably gonna lose again.
You might be right.
He might be right.
It's only thing that bothers me.
I think you on is one of the greatest
games of all time with the greatest
fighters,
but it's just when I see them like,
oh,
you're,
you're just going,
you're going about the wrong way.
And she goes,
you know,
I even talked to Rhonda and you know,
she said she had to wait,
come like,
no one's dealt with loss is worse than
Rhonda.
You don't want to preface that.
You don't want to reference that at all.
Right.
I don't want to see that out of you,
Ana.
She has so much more work to do.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also,
you want to had a long career in Moy
Tai,
a long career.
You know,
like a lot of fights.
Yeah.
Tons.
Lot of kickboxing,
sparring,
a lot of MMA sparring.
Sometimes your changes goes,
I mean,
this is a,
this is a real,
sometimes you change,
just go.
You didn't get the Chin thing too.
I don't know.
I see.
I think it's too early to call for that,
especially at that weight class.
I think for her it was more,
she just wasn't being respectful of rose
or thought she was gonna walk through
and all the shit talking and she was
doing and rose is a different animal.
She,
she reminds me of Brian or take a little
bit where she's very dangerous on,
on conventional and the certain spots
you can't train for.
So she's that type of animal with
similar Brian Ortega.
But with Yolanda,
if a gun to my head,
I'd say you ana winds by decision.
But again,
I hate bacon.
Pigs makes me feel badly.
Yeah,
making picks is tough man because you
know you're going to piss people off and
you know,
oh we're fucking rooting against.
But that's,
no,
you have to look at the analysis of it
before the fight.
I thought rose was in trouble.
I'm like,
you want is very hard to take down.
Her Stanhope is world class and I think
she's,
she could very well pick rows apart and
you know,
and,
and crack or she's coming in.
But when she hit her with that left and
she hit her before that and hurt her,
but when she hit her with that left
hook,
I was like,
Gee,
explosive too.
She looks good man.
And rose like a on the embedded rose was
a pat barry takes a giant box of tennis
balls and throws tennis balls at her and
she's popping tennis balls in the air
and she,
she looks fucking solid and rose to her
ceilings.
We're just seeing it.
She is so much room for growth to show
young and pat and she trev around her
and now forever people are like,
you're going to be world champion.
And when everyone tells,
coaches tell fives all the time,
but what actually happens?
You Go,
Oh shit,
they're not bullshitting.
They're not just saying this.
And I think it when she actually
believes it.
Now you're dealing with different thug
rose.
You're dealing with different Yolanda,
you,
Ana doesn't think she's the greatest
gift to the MMA world.
So that con combination,
it's such a fascinating and fight and no
one's talking about it.
Yeah,
well everyone was so caught up in this
cancellation and the Ferguson could be
fight was so huge for the hardcores for
sure,
but it's also one of those things where
with rose coming into this fight now and
you want to make any excuses for the
last fight,
you know,
I'm really interested to see what
happens when they square off.
I can't wait for that fight.
Each other is yawn again and do the same
talk and again and roads can reciting
the Bible.
I don't think she can.
I don't think.
I don't think you'll want to can do the
same talk and you don't.
You don't think she goes,
this was a fluke.
I'm doing the exact same thing.
No.
I think rose going to stare right
through her fucking soul again and be
like,
I'm the champion.
When you talk a gang of shit at someone
and they just stare right through you
and then they merch you in the first
round.
It's very tough to talk all that shit
the second time.
It's going to be interesting.
I think that's a sign if you want.
It isn't respecting rose again.
If she gets up there and start talking
that shit.
I would put a ton of money on rose.
Yeah.
If I see her doing the same things,
I'm like,
Oh shit.
You learn nothing.
Go there.
Nothing.
Well,
it's whether or not rose can clipper
again.
If rose charges in and clips or again,
it's also the thing about a striker
always worried being taken
down is more likely to get hit with a
shot like Kevin randomly when he knocked
out Mirko Cro cop.
Same thing like Kevin was the threat as
a wrestler.
Leaps in with a left hook and catches
him right on the chin.
Knocked him the fuck out.
I think there's a,
there's a real correlation there.
I wouldn't be surprised if you on a sole
focus on improving her stand up and you
know,
it's like God,
I caught this time.
Just get overwhelmed or to stand up.
She gets submitted.
She overlooked the submission game of
rose,
which is actually rose's best weapon.
That's what I was thinking.
I was thinking bro,
we might see rose throw a flying arm.
Correct.
We might see rose wild shit doesn't care
about being on her back.
Oh No.
And she's fast.
She,
she goes for shit.
She like,
she's a wild explosive person,
you know?
And she's a really interesting thinker
too.
You know.
She had a tough life man.
Yup.
Tough life growing up and develop this
very strong mind because controlled
chaos is what I taught and she's
brilliant at.
Yeah.
I think what else about fascinating
about this?
Not that fight,
definitely.
I'm more,
almost more excited for that fight to
anything now.
But what's fascinating to me is everyone
talks about conor Mcgregor,
right?
Especially when you're talking about one
55 and with connor and Max Holloway.
Connor's never looked back.
Went Back,
fight that guy back there.
Even though I'm better than the thing
that gets caught her out of bed I think
is the challenge and making history.
And I think if Khabib or Max where to
win,
that would be a new challenge and he'd
be an underdog against,
could be.
Even with Max Holloway,
the FT,
you have a history at 55 especially if
could be where to win.
I think we see connotate that fight now
cause he goes,
that's about frown.
Great.
Well I'm the best at moving backwards
hitting dudes.
I bet you I can beat that guy.
And we see him.
I think we see him take that fight and
I've never said that before.
I've,
I've always,
I know Dana said,
oh they're going to fight and rush.
I'm like,
God,
why would counter fighting him?
And then I think about like when you
think of all the challenges and college
career and what gets them going,
it's not people behind him.
It's always when people go,
that guy's the best of you is cool.
Give me that guy.
Very similar.
Max Holloway.
Mm.
Yeah.
If Max wins for sure they have a
rematch.
100% a hundred percent the thing about
Khabib is you always got a wonder who is
avoiding him.
There's a difference there.
It did see the differences.
Max is one of the best fighters on the
planet.
No doubt.
He's one of my top,
one of my top guys.
Maybe you were just ever top
featherweight of all time,
but people aren't avoiding him now.
It's like I said,
can be,
it's a different animal.
They are fine.
Guy Referenced this,
I said,
I said if you gave me a choice to make
the walk against Francis or could be,
I'm cherry picking Francis Cause there's
a quick death and not the head in the
third row,
but it's quick.
It could be,
but it's like an isis videos can be long
drawn out and to be a fucking nightmare
that you're not going to forget.
Yeah,
he's going to beat your body into a
pulp,
but it the worst is he breaks you where
it's like,
oh you are good at this.
And people thought you were mentally
strong.
Watch this now your entire family and
friends going to see how much of a pussy
you are as they bashed your brains in
round after round,
after round,
after round.
You see
him break guys too though.
You see like there's something happens
to them when they just,
they give in to the inevitability of
getting ragdoll.
He's just better.
Yeah.
Oh the only person that's going to beat
him.
It's not a person.
It's a fucking grizzly bear.
You know?
It's like,
fuck this man,
and you see you can't see it in their
eyes where it just changes were just
like,
nope.
Not Happening.
How many rounds for four more rounds of
this?
This is terrible.
If he wins and he beats Holloway,
I guarantee you he's calling out
mcgregor.
He wants the GSP fight.
Khabib wants GSP.
Holy Shit.
That's what I hear.
Whoa.
That's the second one.
70 whoa.
What a great fight,
right?
It's a perfect time to do it right now.
Right?
GSP wins by rear naked,
choke against bisping at one 85 says he
doesn't want to fight it.
A five again here,
take your belt,
suck it cs,
GSP.
Just go suck it.
They can take your time.
Know I told you I'd fight their,
sought to whatever you want to do with
that belt.
I'm going to just get to do whatever the
fuck I want.
I made a couple million bucks row.
I'm gonna kick back for Awhile and now
you get party.
Oh,
you fancy yourself a grappler.
Just me too.
Let's party.
That's a really interesting,
if I can make a super fight.
If I was like Dana,
scrooge mcduck,
there's sin on top.
All these gold coins.
I call it Ben African.
I'm like,
Yo,
any interest in fighting Khabib at one
70 fuck yes.
Fuck.
What's up bro?
That's what I'm talking about.
Yes.
Call your boy.
My boy.
I'm going to tell you blocked calls.
We call your boy.
You block your call.
I don't call him,
but I'm sure you collected into him this
weekend.
I want to talk to him this weekend.
That would be the fight,
but you know the thing would have been
asked her and wins.
He starts talking Shit Calling Dana.
Perfect.
Fuck you.
Perfect egg head.
It works.
It sells papers.
It's the bottom line.
Yeah,
but then you ruin Khabib.
If ben asking,
it could be,
I think you give Ben ass grin a guy
who's a good fighter.
GSP.
Well you haven't seen it.
Most people don't know who ben Askern
is.
The problem is he fought in bellator for
so long and then even when bell tours
gotten bigger on Spike TV,
he was off in one FC,
which you have.
No ones are huge.
Ben Asks from fans now,
but we are hardcore,
like the casual fan has no idea.
Like who is this guy with the curly hair
they're sending to his death,
but we can sell it because he speaks
well.
He's a beast on the mind and then you
pin it,
gets hit an Olympian.
He's never,
he was undefeated.
Never been hit against Khabib.
Yeah.
And we call it the Cold War,
I think in the UFC,
particularly me.
Well,
I'm a big Ben,
her and Dick Rider and Jimmy Smith,
who's also a big Ben Aspirin Dick,
right?
Think we're all Dick,
We could sell the shit out of it.
I could hype the shit out to be 100%
honest in the process.
I think he's something special,
I think is grappling is very unusual.
Very difficult to prepare for.
And if you're going to deal with Khabib
against a guy who can neutralize his
stuff,
and then we see like,
what did we see Khabib on his back?
Ben Ass Grin fucking
would a knee across the belly punching
Khabib in the face.
And we're like,
no.
What about Ben asking on this?
Right?
We can be just doing the ground and
pound.
Right.
There's these tray crazy scrambles and
the grappling communities can be like,
it would be amazed is terrible.
Striking good looks on that to Uncle
Dana.
Uncle [inaudible] for,
for,
for fuck you.
He's going to slam that phone down.
Fuck you.
He would have to have,
he's like,
sir,
I'm trying to finalize cm punk floyd
here.
You're talking about Penn Aspirin could
be how tear you.
He would have to have a good
relationship with ben asked me and they
would have no,
he does not ease.
I disagree.
No,
he doesn't know.
He can go.
All right.
I'm gonna make money off this kid I have
for $50 million.
They make money off this kid.
Let me do this.
Don't you think you'd have to put Ben,
ask her in in a UFC fight though against
some money to show everybody what he's
capable of.
Nope.
He has all those belts.
Undefeated Olympian.
We just promo the shit.
He's on embedded.
He's on Uca night.
He's on below the bellies on jre.
We go on this campaign.
He's dressed in oak flag.
He's like,
watch me beat the shit out the pound for
pound grain Russian.
Who else doesn't like Russia?
Raul?
Yeah,
Maca.
Great.
Ooh,
I like it.
It's never happening.
Right?
That's never happening.
Not what you sold me.
Thank [inaudible].
Just get to listen to this video.
Dana.
Uncle d,
if you just have him fight someone who's
really good,
like Neil Magni or Carlos condit,
have him as introduction up like fucking
Kobiashi talk.
Watch that introduction fight.
And who knows?
Nope,
this is a one shot.
Hell Mary.
We're selling the fuck out of it.
I'm interested because then what happens
to be fighting to a mega cros Kinda and
just like rape some humps on for three
rounds people.
If that's sucked,
man.
I know,
but he probably won't be able to do
that.
Could beep.
So you've gotta watch that one.
We missed the boat style is so much more
suited to one fc because they allow
those knees to the head on the ground.
True soccer kicks in,
but they still are soccer kicks in.
When IFC it,
did they stop it after Brandon Vera?
Like almost an excuse to dude.
I thought maybe.
I think they still do it.
How about the Roger worked at one.
Oh my God,
your worth to got head kicked by the
time about Roger Work does fight and Ben
Henderson this weekend that's flying
under the radar.
It is fine.
Under the word.
Well it's like,
you know,
worked out was the first ever MMA
fighter on the cover of sports
illustrated.
People forget that.
People forgot that back in the day.
Was this like 2000 twoish threeish he
was coming up right before that.
I forget who he beat then.
He was supposed to fight Kenny Florian.
If you remember,
he was like the front cover.
What year was that?
2004 two nine five no in that too.
Then six dot six six was to say,
Oh yeah,
here's the head kick.
So the dude uh,
is,
is already beaten him.
He rag some horses down and look at
this.
This is horrible.
Oh,
I mean,
that was one of the worst head kicks
you'll ever see.
That was horrible.
Let's see.
I don't want to see that.
I don't want that in my,
that's horrible.
That one's horrible.
Like that guy was,
he was already hurt and out of it before
that.
Um,
well the average casual adult soccer
player can kick a ball with a thousand
foot pound force.
The average professional soccer player
can kick it about 1000,
200 foot pound force.
My educated guesses,
elite highly trained martial arts
perform very similar to the professional
segment.
I'll tell you what,
you put somebody down in their hands and
knees and I kick him in the head like
that can be a lot more than that.
They're fucked.
He might broken,
killed a guy.
You know,
you don't want to see them.
You could,
you could kill somebody doing that.
You literally could snap their neck is
no doubt about it.
When was that sports illustrated cover
though,
Jamie?
Yeah.
Cause you met Roger worked at sports
illustrated illustrated.
I want to and it says,
is Emma,
is the UFC the next emerging sport or is
it just a fad or something like that?
I want to say 2006.
Two.
I'm thinking of six.
I think it's post.
Um,
it's post tough.
Yeah.
It's post Stephan Bonner,
forrest griffin.
And that was 2005,
maybe seven,
maybe seven.
Okay.
Um,
remember Roger worked,
he got all that notoriety and then he
tried big Dick in the UFC when now I
want this,
this and this though.
It cool.
We're going to sit ya and then give you
the worst matchup possible.
Here's gray maynard.
Yeah.
May 28th,
2006.
Oh,
there it goes.
Ah,
mother.
So we're in the neighborhood.
They were closed.
So this was a,
you know Roger where it,
it was like the poster board,
Handsome Hispanic,
Latino,
bad motherfucker.
I remember watching her work to beat
that dude up.
That punched a chicken.
The face like a guy named sterile in
Austin,
Texas.
He's a big football player.
They black sucker,
punched a girl in the face in front of
everybody,
dropped her and then Roger where to
takes his shirt off and fuck's this dude
up.
There's a scramble.
You see the dude squaring off Roger's
way more than him.
Cut to a few seconds later.
See Roger [inaudible] soccer kicking
him.
Here it is.
Okay.
So Roger is standing back here and this
guy steps into this girl,
tmz son.
Did you show the first beginning of it?
Yeah,
but at the beginning of his,
when he steps in and punches the girl in
the face.
All right,
the we'll drop the girl go to right to
the beginning.
Knocked the girl out right to the
beginning.
It doesn't play the whole thing.
So the guy,
the the guy in the orange shirt,
big ass dude drops a girl.
Female girl face.
They look were to look at them.
Yeah.
Good luck colon back talking shit.
He's saying that's a girl man.
He's so much smaller.
This guy is like fuck you.
I'll fuck you up to work.
To always had good fashion to just want
the other than up there.
There's another video.
This we hear more volume when I'm
talking to each other.
This might be the only one I've ever
seen.
Oh there it goes.
Worth to take your shirt off.
And he's pissed guy who had girl roger
work done took their off.
Okay.
We got some titties with a sub.
Roger chases him down.
Well,
Roger was fast as fuck to that.
Oh yeah.
No idea what he's doing before he knew
animal before he knew what that dude's
getting punched in the face and at the
end you see Roger's got to do in the
ground sock kicking them.
No,
it's like,
it's like jumping into the water and
there's a crocodile in there.
Before you know it,
we'll get roger.
Boom.
He's out cold.
You're not.
And that's justice,
isn't it?
It needs to be JC.
He's making a Mexican Batman there.
If he kept kicking him,
it had been justice.
I mean it was justice for sure.
But fuck that guy.
Now some guy's cock sucker punching your
daughter.
Big giant,
250 pound football player.
Sucker punches her daughter killed.
Kill.
Very hard.
Not Super hard not to pick.
Very lucky he's alive.
Yeah,
very lucky.
He's alive.
And you probably shouldn't be if he
doesn't feel remorse for that sucker.
Punching a girl in the face like that.
It's a special kind of piece of shit.
Big Dude too.
It's a giant.
Yeah.
I mean who knows what the fuck is going
on in his head.
But then again,
who knows what the fuck is going on with
a lot of football players that have
suffered a lot of head trauma.
True.
Or he could just be a bad guy.
Could be a bad guy maybe is raised
around that,
thinks it's okay.
Maybe who knows what the girl did either
way.
Never.
Okay to hit a girl fuck like that too.
It's,
that's a horrible thing to watch.
It's a horrible thing to watch.
This gets awful.
That guy punching a guy like you is
horrible but punching a girl in the
face.
Horrible man.
There's a lot of fucking shit of humans
out there,
man.
Sip a real unfortunate part about us,
but keep going.
Dark Dow.
It's a hard,
tough not to when you watch something
like that,
but the Roger Roger,
their day he did man superhero style.
I bet that guy a bit.
His friends,
I remember that time yet.
Burke by Roger worked at the and really
is tiny thought 155 pounds and your
giant ass is all juiced up in the God
damn weight room every day and you still
got knocked out for hitting a girl.
Remember that asshole every day.
Ever lived that down?
Nope.
Even now,
I'm sure people will find them on
instagram.
Be like,
Hey rogen,
we're talking mad shit about you man Mir
that we'll never get to live it down if
he never went to jail for that.
That's the punishment.
Correct.
He never went to jail for that.
You supposed to go to jail for that?
Yeah.
That's supposed to put you in jail for a
long time and hopefully he doesn't have
kids.
Stark.
We won't talk again.
Wait,
go dark sometimes.
What else is on this car this weekend?
Yet?
She has a uh,
anti pedis.
That's a fun one.
Everybody's dad slept on that fight.
It's another one that's gone under the
radar.
She has both pet dies.
Very interesting man.
Jessa man,
he fucking submitted by Neil Dariusz.
He gets your back.
You're Foxville remembered he got
submitted by Kevin Lee.
He did,
but he didn't.
He didn't,
he didn't get submitted.
The referee stopped it.
I know,
but he was saying he was good.
He look,
he,
he was tightening up his neck.
Yeah.
It wasn't even that.
You got to let the guy go out.
I'll come on brother.
100%.
He was felder.
I Quinta.
Whoo,
whoo.
Do
Cater.
Did you see you might have caner
fighting him past monster Calvin cater
and a [inaudible].
That's a good fight to go.
Look at the undercard.
You got bored.
You've got Joe Lozan on quarter.
Calvin cater to a more economy.
That's a great fight.
Fight of the night.
Written all over it.
All over it.
God,
there's fucking five excellent fights in
that main card.
Like your boy fleets hit or look at your
girl fleets hearing.
Yeah,
ver versus Carolina voc of Itch.
And then I'm not even mad at the fight.
Pass.
Fight the,
uh,
your boy Bruce Leroy versus low Bob
who's off the team.
Connor and then team could beep saw each
other and they got into it.
They thing the other team,
connor,
and then the team could bebes got
brilliant to it.
Cause kimmy obviously asked for connor
when Tony Fur fell out and Dana was
like,
come on,
let's get real.
Yeah,
you can't put that better shot at read.
There's a video supposedly have a Lope
off calling him a coward and like he was
calling them out and to say it to his
face.
Oh Wow.
Those guys from uh,
Pakistan.
This is Dagestan,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
people he must've seen get killed shit.
Now Margaret Madoff,
like mentally,
he's in a completely different space.
Goddamn Mike can be in color.
Why don't they have Mike Rodriguez,
Mike and Black and white.
White.
Is He in Dad's ashes?
This bullshit.
What is this bullshit?
They didn't even,
it didn't even allow them to flex.
God Damn Mike.
He's the fucking regular russell shorts
on that you get in gym class.
Fuck Mike.
Oh Man.
Oh Joe Lowe's on ons on the car too.
Mike slow.
Mike Rudd.
That's not a great nickname.
Uh,
slow Mike.
That's not good.
That's a trek as fast.
So fast.
They couldn't get him a color picture.
Um,
light heavyweight,
look at that one,
two Oh five and one 92.
What is that?
What's that shit?
This is that real weight?
Is it always not in one nine two one of
them is two oh five ones.
One 92.
That doesn't even make any sense unless
they're fighting an 85 and they caught
them before the wake.
That makes zero sense.
One guys,
13 pounds heavier weight class they
finding,
I mean no,
I know that's,
that's light heavyweight.
But what is Mike?
Mike Rodriguez with Shane's name for
black black dye.
Last name Mike or Rodriguez to be Cuban
maybe.
Um,
his name's Mike though.
Slowmo Mike.
But um,
if he just fortunate he had a picture
cause usually this throw up a shadow if
they don't have it right this time
though.
You know what?
You're not going to shout out.
We're going to black and white for him.
We're going to let people know that you
haven't really fought in the UFC before
so it give you,
but we're still getting pictures.
What do you think about Tso and Pedis?
Ah,
man Pedis,
right?
It's just bad streak.
He's on a rough streak.
He won his last one,
right?
But then him find a 45 whoever told him,
dude,
that's insane.
So what tell Holloway got his belt.
But I'm a Kevin Lee Fan,
but I say he did not submit.
Michael had it.
They should have let him,
they should have let them go out and he
would have won,
but they didn't and he didn't.
Okay,
well we're in the same boat.
However,
if it would have kept going on,
he had been choked unconscious.
Not,
maybe not.
I've been doing Jujitsu made too long.
Not to know the is like Hicks,
Gracie,
Hixon,
let's black belts take his back with
full rear naked choke.
And it's like,
go ahead.
I know.
Crazy.
Right to chocolates.
That's,
that's,
you know what Gracie,
we're talking that takes,
and for Gosh Sakes,
that's a,
I love Chia Aza.
That's a far cry from pigs and Gracie.
But also he went to go tap.
Have you look at the video,
look at the video.
He,
he panics a little bit.
And now he's a,
he's a,
he's a black belt,
I think he said he knows what the fuck
he's doing.
He was going hot and trading on his
neck.
If you hear him talk about it that he
tightened,
he put all his focus on his neck and he
let his hands go and it's just
tightening.
Oh yeah.
You have Kevin Lee who's a fucking
anaconda around your neck.
Yep.
And has previous winds of rear naked
choke.
I don't buy it.
I agree with you.
They should have let it go on.
I think we'd been choked unconscious.
Gotta let it go on.
You have to got to let it go on.
The only worse rest I've seen was the
ref in the,
uh,
Joseph Parker fight.
I didn't see the judge.
The Ref would not fucking let these guys
fight.
Anytime he got close,
he jumped in there and push them away.
Hmm.
Who Do you think that favored?
They,
I think they thought it was going to
favor anthony.
Joshua for sure.
They want him to win,
but actually favored.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
you agree with the decision?
Yes.
Parker definitely lost,
but I can only agree where people are
like,
oh Auntie Joshua look batty an off
night.
No,
no,
you morons.
The,
and polly mentioned this,
the distance they fall in such a high
level,
no one got hit and Parker's such a good
boxer.
His Jab is so goddamn good.
It was just a battle of straight skill
man.
And I thought it was so impressive and
people walk away from gun man,
Anthony Joshua is not that good.
It man,
he's better than I thought he can box.
But,
and I thought,
well it's cause you understand the
people that say what?
It's not that good cause he didn't win
by spectacular knockouts like Deontay
wilder.
Correct.
Wilder.
That's uh,
that's interesting.
The wilder fight is very interesting
because while their talks a ton of shit,
he's exciting.
He's brash,
he's got serious knockout power.
Crazy.
He,
he's fun to watch matt and he's like a
brash American,
you know,
that's a great,
it's a great fight.
What are they going to do?
That it was wilder.
I have to fight somebody first.
It sounds like josh was going to fight
someone else.
And wilders going fight song.
Why are they doing that?
That's so stupid.
So stupid.
Dropbox in this.
It's so stupid.
Well,
they build it up to make this big giant
event and when it comes off like,
look,
it comes off,
it comes off like Pacquiao versus
mayweather giant.
It's the number one problem with boxing.
Give us the matchups.
Everyone wants to see.
That's why the UFC gain so much ground
because usually day and besides the
aspirin and could be usually when
there's a fight,
danny goes,
boom,
there you go.
Super.
You want to see steep ADC.
Boom.
There you go.
Yup.
Colorado.
Boom.
There you go.
So we get all the calmer and the Albert.
So we get these super fights in boxing
like,
no,
listen,
we want to do this and this guy's a
mandatory.
I manage this guy and this guy's PBC
bucks and sketch show showtime.
So saw this red tape.
It'd be a phenomenal fight.
Phenomenal fight.
It's going to happen.
I think it happens.
I don't know if happens under this year,
but I just can't believe triple g and
Canelo are not going to fight that such
a both.
I feel like it's not even,
I mean what is today date is April 5th
it's a month away and they haven't even,
they haven't even put the,
uh,
the,
the hearing together,
the hearing is like what the 18th
there's some cml.
It backed out.
Why did he back out?
I just don't the,
I think he knew the odds were against
him and backed out and then,
you know,
triple g stills planning on finding May
5th wow.
Still going to fight.
And I was hoping for,
is he gonna fight?
I'd love it if he fought Billy Joe
Saunders.
But Joe Saunders camp fight till June.
So why triptan cause he has,
he's coming off a hand injury but he's
like,
I'm ready in June,
let's do an in June.
If I'm cooking,
if I'm triple g I'm not finding May 5th
you're going to sell 30 paper views.
If the wind tunnel drops out,
whoever they replace with,
it's not gonna be a huge name.
I'm sure it's can be a tough guy.
It's gonna be a worthy opponent.
Can Be tough.
You know,
it's not gonna make you bank.
You make bank up your paper view just
fighting June fight,
fight fucking uh,
Billy Joe Saunders in June for us.
Yeah,
but the problem is they don't have the
date in June when you look at a venue
like the tee ball mill arena in Vegas,
that motherfucker is booked up for UAA
in advance except for the mayweather.
Mcgregor fight.
The Mayweather Mcgregor fight.
They found an opening.
I said let's do it because now you're
dealing with the boxing commission.
Yeah.
Didn't have to pay.
They have to pay ice cubes.
Basketball League had a book that they
had paid.
Like he's gives basketball league how
much they want daily,
how much they have to,
I heard 6 million,
6 million to w and then they didn't like
the parking lot,
but it's three on three basketball for
so ice cube,
get the fuck out the way.
I'll watch three on three at the rack.
I'm not trying to see these old
basketball players play three on three.
Get the fuck out so we can watch
controverts.
Floyd didn't give us any hassle.
Basketball is three and three league.
I have a bunch of old like college
players and some old NBA players and
they play a three on three half court
game.
Put It on TV.
It was like done every week in a
different city and like a table,
a four point shot.
It's like if there is a master's leak
and you could only use your left jab.
That's what it's like in the UFC for
sons of bitches.
Karate is back.
New World,
full contact,
karate combat league kicks off.
Is this with Bas rutten just announced
today?
Yeah.
Bas rutten is the a commentator.
Commentator.
He's coming on.
He might have something to do with the
organization.
Two bosses coming on next week to talk
about it.
El Guapo,
you're the house boss boss too.
They play in a pit or they fight rather
in a pit.
It's a shape.
It's like Sam pick at it,
look at it,
see it.
I'll bro.
Chuck Norris did this shit and it's the
way to go,
man.
Oh yeah.
Worked out great for chuck.
Look at what did work out great.
He had a lot of successful shows that
have a fight booked.
April 20th wonderboy fight with karate
pants onto it looks like so they're
fighting with little gloves on,
but they're wearing karate pants going
to be in the Olympics.
Not this
exact thing,
but cries and Olympics for the next one.
God is in the Olympics.
Yeah.
I'll tell you right now,
all these fives better.
Pray to God.
Wonderboy doesn't get a feather up his
ass.
I to join this league or Raymond
Daniels.
Yes.
Worldclass guys.
Oh,
you're shooting now.
Can you kick to the legs?
You better be able to kick the legs.
You can fuck it for sure.
Find a sandpit though.
They should fight in a basketball court.
Oh God Nah.
Stop that.
We can't,
I can't say fight in a basketball court
period.
Doesn't get too close to the fans.
Don't want you to close three rounds of
three minutes,
three minutes.
Offensive techniques scored more highly
than counterstrikes.
This is karate is back.
Approximately 50 million Americans have
participate in crowded some point in
their lives.
And then I,
and then I grew the hall.
You got to stop with that.
I grew the fuck up.
Then I realized,
oh,
I'm not learning shit that John Claude
did in the movies and this isn't fun
anymore.
Yeah.
When someone says that approximately 50
million Americans have participate in
karate at some point they're like,
yeah,
little kids taking fucking karate
classes.
My seven year old's awesome man.
Correct?
Yeah,
that's great.
I was a yellow duck out of here.
The problem with karate is we already
know about mma and we already know about
Muy Thai,
but ng Jitsu would I do like is if
they're allowed leg kicks and they have
the small gloves on.
It's basically like it's a MMA fight,
but I'll stand up.
It's all standing,
but also then I can allow like kicks.
God,
it got a lot leg kicks.
That's a huge fuck up.
If they know a lot like cake boss just
to content or is it not?
I know it was promoter.
I don't know how I'm going to want to
find out next week,
but I would have,
I would hope that they allow leg kicks.
I don't even like that.
Gloria doesn't allow elbows.
Straight Cope.
I agree.
I think that's the sport.
The sport is if you're going to stand
up,
it should be more time.
I mean that,
that to me is the sport.
The rules of Morita.
You could throw a wheel kicks in Muay
Thai,
you get through a flying psychics,
you do whatever the fuck you want,
but you also can do Moitai like knees to
the body,
elbows to the face,
all those super effective close range
techniques that glory doesn't allow.
But I think their worry about with the
elbows,
guys aren't going to be able to fight,
you know,
close together because they'll both,
because of the cuts.
However,
I'd rather deal with that then not allow
it.
Oh well I don't like the guys fighting
close together.
I think that's super dangerous,
but when you have guys fight more than
one time and at night,
I think that is fucking crazy.
When you have guys fight two,
three times a night like Joe Schilling
did in the La last man standing event,
that is bananas like you are,
you're taking a giant chance.
You're hoping that someone doesn't get
severely concussed even in a win and
their first fight and then come back and
fight in the sense that make it fun
though,
like that's kind of the nature of the
game.
Like what about wrestling?
They can see double a's.
Those guys,
Russell getting head kicked,
they're cutting massive way.
They are cutting massive weight,
but they're not getting head kicked.
Getting getting head kicked in the first
round and getting up at the count of
seven and the people on later and
fighting and then getting head kicked
again an hour later.
It's nuts.
It's crazy.
I just don't like it.
Just to,
and also you don't get the best guy
versus the best guy in an even right?
Like
if one guy wins by first round,
knock out,
the other guy has a four round war like
Joe Schilling doing.
He fought Simon Marcus,
right?
Crazy fight.
They go to three rounds.
It's a draw.
They go to the third and Joe had been
knocked down I think in that first and
then Joe's arched them in the fourth.
If you know the sport,
you're like,
Damn,
look how these guys just get through
this.
They've dealt with this and now it's
kind of cool,
but,
but we know the repercussions.
Most people don't write well then the
UFC should bring back a tournament to
then.
I'm not mad at that.
The pride tournaments,
it's so old school it's in.
People are probably going to die because
God is so good now,
but it's what you sign up for with the
problem as if one guy goes through three
rounds of hell and the other guy just
lands like a connor straight left hand
they did on Aldo and wins in 13 seconds.
It's just not fair.
I know and you know,
but,
but however that guy pulled off that 13
second knock out another guy had a war.
It's true.
I mean,
Gloria is the only organization right
now that's mainstream where you could
watch guys fight more than once in the
night.
They do it all the time.
Here's the,
here's the point.
Why do UFC is never going to do it in
most sports won't do it.
It's,
it's hard to a,
it's,
it's a long show b,
it's hard to market that it shouldn't be
sanctioned.
No,
I mean there's a reason why it's not
your,
you're in the right here.
There's a reminder tonight,
I play devil's advocate,
but the reason why it's not is because
the mass is,
are like,
well attison it,
we're just saw me get kicked in the face
fighting again.
They sanctioned and for kickboxing,
but they don't sanction that for MMA.
Isn't that weird?
Because like last man standing was in
la.
We saw that at the fucking forum.
That was,
uh,
that was right here.
The whole,
the whole rules are where the judge,
and we've talked about this before and
that's why I was so intrigued about the,
uh,
Tony First and fight,
and this is why I,
I did a standup at,
uh,
this,
San Jose Improv and in the front row and
I didn't know that there can be,
there was all of teammate Kay,
John Fitch Thompson and stuff like that,
and a after the show.
So in,
in front of them asked me this before
first and dropped them at Ferguson.
Could be who's going to win and I I,
it was a toss up for me but because I
thought Tony was going to do work off
his back when he was going to land crazy
amount of elbows and fucked up could be
face but because it could be was on top
he'd get the wind via decision and I
said the losers are going to be the
judges because they won't know how to
judge that fight and say that in front
of the AK team was awkward.
Depends upon how it plays out,
but if it plays out the way you
described it.
Yeah.
If,
if Tony is landing big shots from the
bottom,
submission threats,
elbows,
his face getting bloody but Khabib's
doing work on top,
but Tony's still threatened elbows,
elbows,
this fucking them up.
It's possible but if could be malls but
should be real clear.
We don't judge them when we got it to
see that now and that is a sin.
That's a sin against humanity.
They says we won't.
This is,
we will never see it.
He said,
he said crazy shit like John Jones never
be in a main event again.
He said a lot of crazy shit.
True.
He says this pushing gets a title shot
and then someone else does.
I think he's as emotional.
He's upset.
I'd be pissed too.
But also thinking about money,
he's missed out on that.
That'd be if they tried it again and be
the fifth time trying to promote this.
Is that also really,
this is the fourth they've dropped out
north.
They've tried to make this fight.
That's in Sean Shelby and Joe Sia was
trying to make this fight before he
retired was the one fight he wanted to
make it never happen.
So if you're Dana,
you're like,
hold up,
how much money have we put in marketing
to these fox?
And it just doesn't happen for us.
We're down.
And that does happen.
You gotta do it.
You know,
you said that you didn't believe it was
going to happen until you saw the door
bolt and they're standing next to each
other and here we are.
Yeah,
you're right.
It's such a shame.
You're the first person I text when I
saw it cause we were talking about how
sad weepy.
It's a jet bomber.
But this is the next best thing.
No,
the next best thing is connor.
This is the next best.
Next.
The next.
This the next best thing on a six days'
notice.
Yeah.
You would never get connor on six days
notice.
But if connor would have,
connor was scheduled to fight.
See the thing about a connor at this
stages,
there's no tuneup fights.
It's,
there's never,
it's never going to happen again.
No.
Like every fight is just giant.
Only fight where where it'd be a level
playing field would be nate diaz cause
he's been out just as long.
So you're both going to be,
have a little bit of ring rust.
You're both can be out for a long time.
You're both going through the same
thing.
You fight a guy like Khabib.
Do you think they offered it to nate?
Who Do think they offered it?
So we know they offered it to the Ortega
Ortega.
Eddie Alvarez.
Ann Alvarez had no,
right?
Yeah.
Why did he say no?
I'm not sure what shape too.
Oh yeah,
he's one 90.
He's been doing it too long.
He said,
he's like,
I'm not making that son.
He said it.
I'm all of one night.
I love Alvarez.
Imagine losing 35 fucking pounds.
How much?
And if you know,
please say it for everyone,
how much you think they paid Max
Holloway to take this site?
Six Day notice.
And they go,
Bro,
we know you're a champ at one 45.
Here's the offer.
No Way.
We're just giving you this much.
All I know is what Eddie told me on the
podcast about Tony,
you said he was going to make millions.
So if that's what we know,
we got,
assume there's a big paycheck in it for
Max Holloway.
I told,
uh,
Brian Goes,
how much you think he's in pain?
I said,
if I'm Max,
I don't take that fight for under 4
million.
I know they're,
they're in a tough position and they
need a big name.
And then trying to recoup the paper
views.
So I got them backed in a corner.
I'm on the,
uh,
longest winning streak.
I'm saying 4 million or bust your bold
man.
I'd say two till after taxes.
That's not worth it.
That's fucked that out when you're
fighting Khabib.
Ah,
no.
I need a million for every day.
So six days.
So he,
so you know,
you know,
Max can submit people,
but we don't anticipate him.
Surbiton could be.
It just,
it seems like to be grappling is on a
higher level than Max.
It seems like the way Max can win this
fight is by pacing because Max is,
even if Max is not in shape,
he's in phenomenal shape.
I mean he's just,
he's got an incredible cardio and he
really knows how to pace himself very
well.
Pacing if it's more of a style of fight
and if it's at his temple to [inaudible]
watch a tempo and just throws in a
blender.
Yeah,
he's so,
and it's a six day notice and it's a Max
who was taking time off,
spend time with his family.
So all the chips are stacked against
Max,
all of it.
And it's a weight class above his weight
class.
It's a Khabib who's a huge one 55.
It's arguably the best grappler in the
UFC.
And the other promise,
he really doesn't attain the standup
game.
So your chance of the,
the one,
the home run shot,
it's even dropped even lower.
That's what I'm saying.
Four mill.
Did you hear what he said about it?
He said,
thank you for taking fight.
I don't think you'll ever be the same
again.
Oh,
I said I have foss.
I don't think,
oh,
that'd be the same again.
And he's probably not aligned.
That's a dark thing to say to not just,
Oh my God,
I would never be the same again.
Uh,
it breaks my heart did.
We might say,
hope he's wrong.
And you know what I do if I was in Max's
corner and if,
and if it's like halfway through that
second round and I'm like,
damn,
maxx looks exhausted.
He's not in shape.
He's just taking a beat and he's so
tough.
He's probably the last five rounds.
I've thrown that towel.
I'm gonna take all the shit for the,
from the fans because I don't want Max
dealing with this because this isn't,
this isn't his fight to be honest.
This is in his fight.
This isn't,
his path was going to make 4 million
round hopefully.
And he's gonna be set for life
financial.
If he's smart with his money.
However,
this isn't his path.
We did this to help out the UFC.
He made bank.
There's a towel.
Fuck you.
I know you're,
you're in hate me Max.
We'll talk in Hawaii over bull of a Ahi
tuna.
That's not a bad idea.
Well,
if we know we,
I think with a cubby fight,
one of the things is after the first
round,
you kind of know how it's going to go.
Well,
no,
and split the thing from act two.
If he had 12 weeks and he's in
phenomenal shape and he gets taken down
all a kind of Chad Mendez,
conor mcgregor when cargo tank,
now we're all like,
it's just matter of time where mountain
mount of time you're going to catch him.
But with this could beebs in better
shape.
He's had more time.
He's been preparing for a guy who's
insane cardio shape.
So it's just the odds are so fucked from
act crazy,
crazy.
Really quite stressed.
So stressed as I was unexplained myself,
I'm stressed out.
Wow.
It's going to be interesting to me.
Interesting man.
That's going to be a good one.
So we were talking before it,
lets wrap this up,
but before talking about for this,
we want to do a fight companion,
but there's no fights that were all
around for a fight companions.
So let's,
let's do a fight companion.
Get all the boys in here and put on some
fights during the random night or
something like that.
Ran like a fucking Tuesday or some shit
and my,
maybe you pizza us.
Yeah,
I'm hearing pizza now and then we'll
wait.
We'll save for a cheat meal.
Well how about neither one was cheat
until that night.
Okay.
Deal.
It's a deal deal.
I'll get the pizzas.
Let's wrap this bitch up.
Brenda's job.
A big brown breakdown.
No below the Pelicans.
No worries.
Well not the podcast is renamed below
the belt.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Oh it's still on my show.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
Michelle,
below the belt.
Yeah.
[inaudible] name of your podcast,
just so it's all in.
Go.
Yeah.
Okay.
I like it.
Yeah.
Like it.
Next episodes,
a number four episode next Wednesday
night,
and then she sat k.com
find the kid and then a Friday night
bakersfield.
There's 30 tickets left this Friday
night.
Bakersfield timber.
Brewering some joey is,
is that,
you can see good spot.
I love Bakersfield.
That was exciting and fun,
man.
I had a great time in bigger shit on
there this Friday night.
And then,
uh,
April 20th,
21st Calgary Yuk.
Yuks boom.
Beautiful.
Houston.
June.
Okay.
Love you.
Bye everybody.
Yeah.